this is a great project to improve your
front-end skills you will build an SEO
optimized blog with nextgs content layer
and Tailwind CSS codebux created this
course he has created many Great Courses
on his own channel and we're excited to
share this course with the free code
Camp audience
the course is designed to be a One-Stop
resource for Learners who want to create
their own personal blog website with a
bunch of features including SEO
optimization dark and light themes
responsive design and markdown based
blog rendering let's start learning hope
you are all doing great today we are
going to create something very useful in
our developer Journey there are multiple
options where we can share our learning
through writing such as hash node Dave
medium Etc but I always like to have my
own blog as a developer where I can
customize anything I want so today we
are going to create this amazing blog
using next.js and content layer so as
you can see right now
Let me refresh this and so we have this
minimal
navigation bar which has uh you know
just for options one is the theme
switcher and other two pages are the
about and contact and on the right side
we have this social media icons and the
logo on the left
now uh in the cover section uh I'm
displaying the latest blog that I have
published
we have category block title and a small
description and the cover image now
let's uh scroll down
next section is for the featured post
this section is manually customizable by
you so that
you can show posts that you wanted more
attention or you think it's uh best for
visitors
and the next is the recent post section
where we are going to show the last six
post
at the end we have an uh really simple
footer
uh that has this input and a submit
button now in this input you can connect
any third parties services that provides
you the subscription and stuff
also we have a site map as well
now let's check out this blog page
now in the blog page we have this cover
image
title and the category
now here we have details about the blog
such as publish date total views
and reading time
and the category
let's scroll down so on the left we have
a table of content by clicking on any of
this link you can just directly go to
that section
also we can close this Toc as well
so uh this is the blog element that I
have customized for the purple color
so here is the
code block
now this image will use the image
component of the next GS so that it
loads faster
now I have used the markdown to render
this blog
now let's open the category page
so this is the category page that
contains uh blogs relevant to certain
categories so let's click on the
productivity
so it will contain three blocks and uh
all three blogs have the productivity as
their main category or tag
let's click on the JavaScript so in
under the JavaScript tag we have only
one blog
and let's click on this all button so it
will show all the blocks that we have
right now
now let's check out the about page and
as you can see we have this insights
going from right to left
and text on the right and this cute
little image on the left now this image
is generated by Delhi using a Bing
search
and here are the skills
you can list your skills right here
just a small hook to reach out
this link will open the contact page so
let's click right here
and we have this minimal contact page
now on the left we have this cute little
animation by Lottie animation and on the
right we have this form
so I have created this form in a way
that you know looks like a paragraph you
just have to fill in the blanks
now let's go to the home page now
in this website I have implemented a
really good SEO techniques so that your
article can rank better on Google and
other search engines let me show you uh
how the SEO will help you
let's go to the Google and type OG
preview online now OG is an open graph
that is an Internet Protocol to
standardize the use of metadata within a
web page to represent the content of a
page
so uh you can you know consider that as
whenever you share some blog or any link
on the social media it will preview the
content of the link in a beautiful
manner so let's open this first link
copy this URL paste it right here and
let's click on the check website
now on the right you can see the preview
so whenever we are going to share this
website on Facebook it will look like
this
on Twitter on LinkedIn and in the
Discord as well
and here we have some details that will
be shown on the Google search Pages such
as title description and image
let me open any blog
let's copy this link
and paste it right here
let's check it
so whenever we are going to share this
Vlog there will be a title
small description
and the cover image
so I have implemented all the required
meta tags in this website as well
let me close this
let me show you the responsiveness of
this website so let's go to the home
page
open the dev tools and
click
this device toolbar
and let's select iPhone 12 Pro
Let's uh keep the iPhone SC
now as you can see here uh we have logo
and hamburger menu so let's click on
this and it will open this mini nail bar
now uh
unless you close this with uh by
clicking on the hamburger menu this
never will keep at the top
so it's uh convenient for users who want
to keep it this way
scroll down we have WeChat post section
with three blogs
and recent post section with all the
other blogs and the footer
uh let's open the about page
and it looks great on the phone as well
let's open the contact
and looks great
now let's open this blog
now we have a table of content on the
top and after that we have this blog
let's go to any of this title
so it will scroll down to that heading
let's open the category page
foreign
and it looks great
now bear with me throughout this whole
tutorial I'll be your guide every step
of the way breaking down complex
Concepts into easy to follow pieces so
whether you are a tech newbie or an
experienced developer looking to try
building their own blog then this
tutorial is for you so now let's get
started
now let's open this link uh you will get
this link from the description of this
video
and in this repo I have put all the
required project files and the starter
code
so let's go here and copy this make sure
you have a uh node.js installed in your
system and GitHub as well so let's go to
the project folder
if you are on Windows you can just open
the command prompt by going to the
address bar and type CMD
and here we have command prompt
let me use the git command git clone and
paste the URL so now cloning is
completed uh let's open this folder by
going to the
so now cloning is completed so let's
change the directory by using the CD
command and copy this folder name
and paste it now let's use the npm
install command to install all the
required libraries and press enter
once uh it install all the dependencies
then let's open this repo in the vs code
for that you just have to write code and
Dot
now let me show you the list of
libraries that we are going to use so we
are going to use this Lottie player to
render the Lottie animations we are
going to use the Super Bass uh to
capture the total views of each blog
we have Tailwind CSS and content layer
we have GitHub Slugger to
generate slugs for the blog
and we are also going to create generate
the sitemap let me just show you that
if you go down and click on the sitemap
let's copy this URL and paste it right
here
so other sitemap will show each and
every URL each and every blogs now this
sitemap is uh very useful for the search
engines so that they can index each and
every uh one of the blogs from your
website
let's go to the vs code and we will use
react hook form
to get the response from the form
and we have reading time to calculate
the reading time of each blog and we
have few plugins of rehype and remark
now this plugin will help us to form it
and make the content look much prettier
and for the CSS part we are going to use
Tailwind CSS
so let me close this
first let's uh open the Tailwind dot
config.js file and here you will find
the
colors object uh where I have put every
color which we are going to use so let's
copy this
and
first let's remove this we don't need it
and paste it right here
let's uncomment this
uh now uh for those who don't know about
this trailwind.config file now in this
file you can create your customized
theme and add your variables so uh in
this colors we have this five variables
that we are going to use
so I forgot to show you the dark mode of
the website so let me just show it to
you
scroll up and click on this theme
switcher so it will turn the theme into
the dark mode
and as you can see uh now for the slide
theme uh I have used this purple color
as an accent color but for the dark
we'll use this yellow
this combination of yellow and black
looks uh really great
let's open any log
as you can see here in this blog uh it
has a yellow color instead of the purple
now you can also customize this code
block so they will also change these
colors based on the theme light or dark
let's open the about page
[Music]
and contact page
let's go to the home page
let me show you the project files
uh so if you go to this project files
folder you will find all the assets that
we are going to use for uh in this
project we have blog images and blogs
that are already written now in all this
blog uh I have just uh
added the Tailwind documentation text
and all the svgs
and we have this Lottie animation as
well and some icons and site metadata
and all the text that we are going to
use to create this website
now let's open the development server so
go to the command prompt and just write
npm run div so this will open the
development server at Port 3000 let's
copy this
and open the browser
and paste it right here
now let's remove this stuff
go to the SRC and the app directory open
the page.js file and let's remove all
this except the main div
and just write
hello world
let's save this and check the server
and here it is
now those of you who don't know anything
about app directory then you don't have
to worry about anything I will
explain each and every concept so uh let
me start with this page dot JS file
you can consider this page or JS file as
a UI that is you know unique to every
route so uh
for this this page.js file is directly
under the app directory so whenever you
open the slash part
I'm in the home page it will uh always
load the hello world
uh this page.js file now let's uh open
this layout.js file so those of you who
knows the basics of next.js in the Pages
directory we we have a underscore app.js
file and underscore document.js file so
similarly layout.js file is also do the
same work so uh this layout.js this file
will be
shared across all the routes so
if I create any route in this app
directory it will also have this HTML
and body tags and class names so
anything I write here or any component I
render right here it will be also
rendered across all the routes because
this is the root layout file you can
also create a different layout files and
different routes that we are going to do
later on so first let's set up the
phones and we are going to use this
layer.js file like
like this
so uh we are going to use two phones one
is the enter for the blogs and another
is the main rope let me just copy this
and paste it let's change its name to
main rope
and instead of enter let's import the
rainbow as well
from the next slash font slash Google
and let's set display
and this font configuration
to
swept
and let's add the variable name for this
enter fonts for that you have to type
dash dash font and any name you like uh
let's just type in
let's
let's copy this and paste it right here
now for the main row we will change the
variable to Mr
now uh we are not going to use this
class name instead we are going to use
this variable because uh we are using
the Tailwind CSS
so let's remove this
and instead
Let's uh use both of these fonts let's
open the pack text
and
and the currency symbol
open the brackets and write
this variable name Dot
variable
and do the same for the menu up as well
so uh this way uh any component inside
there is children can use any of this
variable names
let's save this and open the Tailwind
CSS here we also have to configure the
fonts so after the colors
press enter and write font family
uh now uh we have two fonts with two
variables called Mr and I in now Mr
stands for the
a menu
and here we have to add the variable
name
by using the VAR
same as we do in the CSS
just write dash dash font
Dash Mr
and copy this and paste it right here do
the same for the inter fonts
let's save this now we can use any of
this font by just writing a class name
such as
font Dash in for the enter and font Dash
Mr for the manual
let's go to the layout.js file so I'm
going to use the main drop fonts for the
whole website unless we have any
component that uses the enter
fonts let me change this to main group
Dot
variable
let's save this
and also let's add some classes in this
body tag so we are going to use Font
Dash Mr which stands for the menu
and set the background to light
which is the white color
and for the dark we are going to change
the background to start
so that's it now instead of using this
brackets every time we want to use the
variable uh there is a different method
that we can use so in the SRC folder
create one folder called
utils which is for the utilities let's
create one file called
index.js file now here we are going to
create one helper function so just write
export const c x
and in this function we will pass the
class names
now we have used this spread operator to
get all the values of class names
and let's use the arrow function from
this class name let's use filter
and the
add the Boolean
right dot join
by space
let's save this and let me explain what
this function do
now here uh we are going to use the CX
function to add multiple classes instead
of using uh the parenthesis this
function except the class names are the
array of class names now we are using
this filter with the Boolean now why
Boolean now this filter will filter all
the falsy values so it can be an empty
string null are undefined
and then we are going to join each class
name
with one space
so let's use this function
go to the layout
and
let's create another class name
here just write c x to import the CX
function from the utils
let's open the parenthesis and let's add
the classes
first we have entered our variable then
mandrope
dot variable
then we have this three class names so
let's pass it as a string
let's remove this
and save it
now let's create the uh navigation bar
let me close this
let's remove this image and this classes
as well
so let's write Flex Flex slash column
items do
Center justify to Center as well now I'm
getting the suggestion of this classes
uh from this extension
here is the extension called Tailwind
CSS intellisense so make sure to install
it in your vs code and also there is uh
one more extension here it is now this
extension will help us to create the
area component faster
so make sure you install this as well so
let me close this
now in the SRC folder let's create one
folder called components
and inside the components folder let's
create another one called the
header
and press enter
now in the header folder let's create
one file called
index.js now let's use the extension to
create the react component just write r
a f c e
and we have this
a small component let's rename this to
header
and Export as well
let's save this now uh as we have seen
in this blog
we are using the same header and the
same folder across all these pages so
let's move this header and footer to the
layout
so that it can be shared across all the
pages
so in the layout before the children
let's add the header component make sure
you uh import this from the components
folder
let's save
let's save this
and check it out
and we have some errors
and the header
and here is our header component
Let's uh remove this black background
go to the
global.css and remove all this let's
save it
and here we have SIMPLE black background
now let's start creating the header
use the header HTML element let's add
the class names
keep the display to full
padding Dash four
pairing X and Y two let's keep it to
and display to flex
items to
Center and justify between
let's save this
so here is the header part let's remove
this black background as well for now
open the layout.js file and remove this
class
save this
so here is the white background
now let's create the logo component
so inside this header folder create one
file called logo dot JS and
write r a f c e to create this logo
component
here we will use the link component as
the parent
make sure you import it from the next
slash link
in the azuref
just write slash
and in this logo we are going to use one
image and the text
so let's add one do
and import the image tag from the next
slash image
in the SRC
we are going to import the image from
the public folder so make sure you have
stored your logo in the public folder
for now you can open the project files
and copy this profile image dot PNG
and
paste it inside the public folder
now any files that you file such as
image or videos that you want to use in
the next years and if you are using it
locally then you must have to uh pass
all those files into the into this
public directory otherwise it will not
render those files
so let's import the profile image from
at
slash
public slash
profile Dash image dot PNG
let's use this image in the SRC and for
the alt you can just write your name
and for the class name let's keep the
width to full and H2 Auto
and rounded to full as well
let's close this image
now after this do add one spawn tag and
just write code
Lux
let's save this
and let's import this logo component
inside this header
let's save it
I think we have some issue in importing
this file let me check the
name of this file again
go to the logo
it can be because of this internet
notation for that you can just go to the
Json dot config
file
so this at the rate slash will replace
uh itself with the dot slash SRC slash
so instead let's remove this and this
so that we can access every folder such
as a public SRC Etc let's save this
and as you can see here here is our
profile image
let's add some classes
and the image container let's add class
names
keep the width to 12.
let's keep it to 16.
round it to full overflow
hidden
border border type 2 solid and Border
color to border Dash dark
let's save it
and it looks great
now in this link let's add the class
name
set the display to Flags items to
Center
set text color to text Dash dark now in
this spawn element let's add class name
set font to
bold
and text size to text Dash extra large
let's save this
and it looks great now uh so let's uh
add some space between this image and
the logo
go to this image container do
right margin right
two
four
save this
and looks much better
now let's create the center part of this
navigation bar
let's go to the index.js file so after
the logo let's create one nav element
and inside this now we are going to use
the link
so make sure you import it
right Edge ref
slash close this
and right
home
copy this and paste it for two more
times write slash
about for the
about page and do the same for the
contact page as well
let's save this
and so we have those three links
and after this navigation bar we are
going to have one more to do
and this will contain the Social Links
and let's add classes let's keep the bit
to the maximum
and padding top and bottom to three
padding left and right to eight
and set border border Dash
solid and Border color to dark set
rounded to full font to medium
capitalize all the text
and display to flex
items to
Center
now let's add class in the link
set Emoji right to 2
same for the about
margin left and right two
and for the contact as well
and let's add one button which will be
the theme switcher for now just write T
let's save this
and it looks great now if you see
closely
this navigation part is not at the
center of this page but instead it is on
the right so let's use the fixed uh
position
so in the class name
add position to fixed
and set top to
six
right to 1 by 2 that means right to 50
and let's Translate
X to 1 by 2 as well so that uh it uh
comes at the center of the page
let's save this
and it looks great
now let's also add the backdrop effect
so that it looks uh blurry on scroll
for that first let's add the background
and set the opacity of the background to
80.
and use the backdrop class
so setback Doppler to SM and save this
for now you won't be able to see
anything but on scroll or whenever some
content goes under this navigation bar
uh you can see the different blurry
effect
now let's add the social media links
so remove this and
add the link element here we are not
going to use the
link element from the next.js because uh
here in the Azure we are going to pass
the website that opens in the new tab or
are the external links
so first is the LinkedIn
then
Twitter
and GitHub and the last one
is the
triple you can add anyone you like
for now let me just write example.com
let's save this
now instead of this names let's add the
icons
so you will find all the icons from the
project files folder
and the SVG folder
now uh we are going to use a different
approach to render the SVG files
so in the components folder create one
file called
icons dot Js
now in this file we will store all the
svgs so first open the LinkedIn SVG
copy this
and in the browser open svgr playground
and open this first link
so this will convert this simple SVG to
an react component so let's paste our
SVG file and
copy this whole component
and paste it inside the icon start JS
file
let's export it
let's name it as Link in icon
and we can manipulate this SVG by
passing different class name from this
props so instead of props let's open the
curly braces and write class name
and the rest of the props so instead of
props just write the rest
and remove this field none
and let's add the class name
let's use CX utility
inside the CX function
we will pass we will add the class name
that we have passed inside this
component
and with this class name let's add
another class
set width to full and height to auto
and let's add the view box because uh it
is important when you resize the SVG
element
just write 0 0
width which is 42 and height which is 43
let's save this
and import it inside the header element
so instead of this just import LinkedIn
icon
let's save this
and it is not defined
so its size is bit bigger
let's add a class name inside this
anchor tag
set width to
6 height 2 6 as well margin right 2 4.
let's save this
and it's still bigger
let's add the display to inline
lock
and it looks better
so uh this way we are going to convert
all the SVG files to a react component
now uh instead of doing uh this for each
and every icon I have already
done that and you can get all the icons
from this icons.js file which is in the
project uh files folder let's copy all
this
and inside this components
and inside this icons dot JS file
paste everything so we have
Sun icon Moon icon for the themes
feature LinkedIn Twitter GitHub and
dribble as well let's save it close the
icons.js file
and let's use this icons
make sure you import it from the slash
icons
thank you
and copy this class name add for each
and every link
let's save this
and it looks great now we have this
scale up and down animation so let's add
it as well
in each icon
we are going to add the same glass so
let's uh select this and press Ctrl d
again and again
this way we can write
the class name in each line
add class name
Set uh on Hover
we will use scale Dash
zero five
and set transition Dash all
is and duration
to
200.
let's save it
let's increase the scale
to 125 let's save it
and it looks much better
now let's add the icon for this themes
feature
and this button let's add the sun icon
for now later we will add the condition
on a theme switch and add the moon icon
as well let's save this
and here we have the sun icon
so our header part is completed now
let's see how we can use content layer
to render the MDX blogs in this Nexus
application
now let's uh open the content layer
website
go to the content layer dot dot Dave
now uh why we are using the content
layer to render the markdown files if
you directly use the markdown in your
Nexus project then you might have to do
more configurations but if you use the
content layer it will directly transform
the markdown content into reusable data
objects that can be imported in the
JavaScript files and content layer makes
it easy to edit the markdown file since
you don't need to reload the page to you
know see these changes now as mentioned
here content layer is a Content SDK that
validates and transform your content
into typesafe Json data that you can
easily import into your application now
if you want to know more about the
content layer you can just go through
this website and read more about it for
now let's go to the documentation
section
and in this environment select next.js
so we have already installed the next
Dash content layer and content layer as
well now uh as mentioned here we have to
make some change in the next dot
config.js file
let me close this
open the ABS code
let's close each tab
and open the
next.js.config file now if you want to
directly open any file in the vs code
just write Ctrl p and
type the file name
and here is the next dot config.js now
let's
go here copy this
and
paste it right here
now we are already exporting uh using
this but instead
let's import like this
and any Nexus configuration can be
uh in exported from here
let's save this
now uh whenever we edit the
index.config.js file we have to restart
our development server
let's start it by using npm run Dev
and there is some error
so this is a simple module related uh
issue
uh let's change this import statement to
something like this const
let's get
let's get with content layer
from the
next content layer using require
let's copy this and paste it right here
and instead of this let's just write
module
dot exports
equal to with content layer
and let's use the spread operator
uh so that any configuration we pass
here can be exported from here
let's save this and
start the development server
let's reload this
now uh
Let's uh go to right here
so we have done this configuration
let's go to the source files
and
as mentioned here this module provides
the method for working with the local
files as your current content Source uh
now for this tutorial we are going to
use the locally stored blocks
so
as a engineer there are three primary
functions in the content layer first is
the make Source uh second is a defined
document type and third is the Define
nested type so let's click on this make
source
now as mentioned here make Source
provides the content layer with the
schema and configuration for your
replica application
the code calling make Source should be
placed in
contentlayer.config.js file so let's uh
copy this name and create one file
let's close this
now uh in the root directory create
one file called contentlayer.config.js
now let's copy this code
and paste it right here
now let's uh add the required option in
this make Source function
so first is the content directory path
so let's uh copy this
and paste it right here
uh we are also going to use the content
folder to you know store the blocks
let's just make one create one four in
the root directory called content and
inside the content let's add one more
folder
and let's name it as Vlog dash one now
block dash one is going to be the title
of that blog so
press enter and create one file called
index Dot
MDX file now MDX stands for the markdown
uh uh actually there are two formats one
is MD and MDX is the newer form uh of
the markdown MDX lets you include the
jsx uh into the markdown so that you can
use the react components inside the
markdown files
uh now uh those of you who don't know uh
how to write in markdown it is uh really
easy I mean uh let's say for uh admin
tag you just have to write hash and type
this is the H1 element same for the H2
just write two hash and this is the
H2
element so uh there are multiple uh
different markdown uh techniques that
you can use create a different content
content now there are different ways you
can import the images in the background
as well let's just uh save this file and
go to the
contentlayer.config.js file
so after the content let's check the
documentation
now this is the content
it will include we don't need this
this is for the exclude
uh now let's check this document types
click on this uh Define document type
now as mentioned here uh Define document
type defines the schema for one
particular document type often referred
to as a model or content type so let's
copy this
and paste it before this make source and
make sure to import this from the
content layer slash source files
now instead of Doc let's write blog
for the name uh let's keep the blog now
for the file path pattern we have slight
different pattern because in the content
folder uh first we'll go to the block
dash one folder and then we will get the
index dot MDX file so let's add
one more and Slash
and add one more so this is the pattern
that is suitable for our content Android
MDX
now uh in this fields we will add all
the required fields that we are going to
render on the website and that we are
going to need in our blog
so let's go to the documentation so
there are
multiple options
first is the name and second is the
fields
and if you click on this field type
so there are different fields available
that you can use
so first we are going to use the string
like this one so title with the type
string
we already have one
now let's uh go to the date
because we are going to need this
published date
let's paste it right here paste it for
one more time here we will
uh use the updated
at
on so whenever you update your blog then
uh you also want to update this date as
well uh let's uh
keep it required fill so just write
required to true
let's do the same for the title and the
updated ad as well
now let's add one more field for the
block description that uh you want to
display somewhere or you want to add it
in the SEO so just add
description
keep the type to string and require to
true
now let's say for the cover image we are
going to use the image
for now I don't think there is any type
for the image
let's search it
let's click on this
row local files
and
as mentioned here we can use this field
to store the URL of the image
so let's copy this
and paste it right here let's uh
keep it as a required field now after
the image uh let's add
one more field call the Boolean
copy this
and paste it after this
let's rename it to is published so
whenever this is true that means the
blog should be rendered on the website
and if it is false that means the blog
can be a draft or it can be old so you
can just make this field false and
that's how you don't have to delete the
whole block file
let's set the default to true
let's copy this
and paste it for one more time here we
will add one field called author
so uh for this project I'm going to
include only one author that's why I
kept it it's a field to string but uh if
uh you have a Blog uh where uh there are
multiple authors then you can uh keep
this type to list
and let's uh add the list type for the
tags so go to right here
copy this
and paste it here so the tags
are the type of the tags is list and and
each element in this list is uh of type
string
so I guess uh this is it this are the
all fields that we are going to need for
this project let's uh save this now uh
let's go to this Define document type
and check out
one more option called computed Fields
now as mentioned here computed Fields
can be calculated on the Fly rather than
being read directly from the content
source so let's say you want uh any
other fields that that required some
data from the blog and then you can
calculate something out of that data and
you want to display that so uh for
example here is the URL path so uh the
type of this computed field is going to
be string and this is one is the resolve
function that
that passes the document uh markdown
document and from that document you can
get the data and you know manipulate
that data and return it to this resolve
function
so in our case uh let's uh create one
completed file for the URL so let's copy
this
and after the fields paste it here
so instead of URL underscore path let's
just write URL now so in this resolve
function we will get the whole markdown
document now as mentioned here they have
used the flattened path
so let's copy this
and
remove this now we are going to render
our blogs at slash blog slash blog title
so just uh write the back text right
slash blogs slash and the
uh currencies uh symbol and curly braces
paste the talk dot underscore row dot
underscore flattened path and let's say
this I think there is some error let's
add the curly brackets
let's save this now here
we have to pass this Define document
type
so just click on the enter
and write document
types
and add
vlog
that's it just save this
and let's go to the
here
I think there is some error I guess it
is because we change this import
here we have made some changes so before
uh there was an SRC so let's go to the
layout file and here just write SRC
slash utils
and do the same for this header as well
slash SRC slash components let's save
this
and here is our website now uh
let me restart this development server
now if you see uh there will be some
details about the content layer
now you will get this warning that
content layer might not work as expected
on Windows
so there is some reference error that
string is not defined because we have no
any information uh defined in this blog
so let's uh
do that now if you want to add the
information about the blog such as blog
title tags Etc then you can add it
inside the section of the block called
front matter so for that you have to go
right here
write dash for the three times press
enter and let's add the title
uh let's add blog
one title
and next is the description so this is
the description for Vlog one
next is the image
uh for this image
we are going to use any image available
in the public folder so let's open this
project files go to the blog images
let's copy this folder inside the public
directory and rename it to
vlogs
enter
so let's import the image
let's
open the public folder slash blog slash
select any image you like
after this let's uh add the published
add date now these are all the fields
that we have declared right here so we
have to fill all these fields so copy
this paste it here
Let's uh change it to published at
and let's add the
date
today is 2023
0 8.
28.
let's copy this and same for the
updated at
next is the
is published let's keep it to true
and next one is the tags so for tags we
are using list so press enter and to add
the list items you have to write a dash
write the
tag name such as productivity
all right C CSS so these are the two
tags and now close this front matter
now after this you can start writing
your blog from here so let's save this
and check this
right here
and we are getting this reference error
called the string is not different let's
see that let's check all the fields one
more time type string required to type
date date
string
out here there is a mistake
we have to add string
and double quotes let's save this
and now
it says missing required field for one
document
so it will skip the document
we have author is missing
so let's go right here
and after the updated add add author
just write your name
save this
and as uh as you can see here it says
generated when documents in the dot
content layer
now if you go up and here is the folder
that is generated and this folder
contains all the generated documents in
this generated folder
so in the blog here you will find this
block dash one dot Json file now this
Json file contains all the details about
this blog
so let's see how we can render this
let me close this
and this as well
now let's open the page.js file and so
now we uh want uh
we want to get this blocks that are
generated from here
so
open this index dot MJS
file
and as you can see here it is exporting
all the blogs files as in all blogs so
let's import it import all logs
from
let's go out and click on dot content
layer slash
generated
Let's uh log this all blocks
save this
and let's open the console
this component is server side component
so it will log all the values in here so
uh here is an array that contains this
one blog
and all its details such as title
published ad updated at
and the body of this blog in the body
there is two of formats one is the raw
format and other is the HTML format
now uh here are multiple information
now we have already used this underscore
raw and flattened path to generate the
URL field which is right here so it is
slash blog slash block title uh in this
case it is block dash one
so this is how we can generate uh
different uh blogs now let's see how we
can render this
so
so in the documentation
go to the
files and click on this generated data
so as mentioned here this is the file
location
and this is the data structure that we
uh we already saw this
let's click on the MDX
and here is the usage index.js
so this is how uh we will render the all
all the blogs
all right so
let me go right here
go to the project files and that is
already a lot of blogs available so just
copy all this into the content folder
select one by one
copy
and paste it inside the content folder
now as you can see the content layer has
generated the required files for all the
blogs
each block will contain this
informations such as title and Etc so
and we will use this poly tag and all
the content inside this body tag so
there are different types such as Raw
and HTML
and that's it
now instead of writing this uh we can
shorten this import so let's uh open the
Json
copy this and paste it right here
let's write
content layer slash generated
and instead of this let's write in
double quotes dot slash dot content
layer
slash generated
so we just have to write this and note
the
whole thing let's save this and instead
of this just write the content layers
less generated let's save this
and we are getting the log
so let's uh create the cover section
now this blog uh we have three sections
one is this cover section next is the
feature post and last one is the recent
post so let's create this
uh go to the components folder let me
close all this in the components folder
create one more folder called home
and in this home folder let's create a
home cover
section file
let's use rafce to create this component
and let's import it in the
this page.js file so instead of hello
world let's import this and let's uh
pass all these blocks
so just write blogs
and
just like this let's save it and
from here
let's get all the blogs
and uh we are going to render the latest
blog in the cover section so for that we
have to short all the generated blogs so
let's create one function in the utils
so open the
index.js file from this utilities folder
and let's create one more function let's
use export
const short blogs
pass the blogs
and this will
return
logs
first let's use the slice and then we
will use the short now in this short or
let's pass to elements of an array let's
pass to block log a Block B
and let's compare its uh
date
so for that we are going to use the
compare
descending from the date Dash FNS
library that we have already installed
so in this function
we have to pass the dates
so this function will compare the dates
uh
let's use parse ISO
and
for the blogs date for the blog a date
just write a DOT published at
and then
fires
ISO
B dot published at
so this function uh
will return an array
which are shorted from latest date to
the oldest one
so let's copy this
go to the Home Cover section
let's create one more variable called
shorted
logs
equal to Let's paste the short blocks
function
make sure to import it
from the utils let's pass all the blogs
now for this cover section we are going
to uh select uh the first log so create
one more variable called The Log and
from the shorter blocks select the first
block
now let's see how we can render this
blog so we will use the
article element
now let's uh render the image so before
that uh first let's see how we are
getting the image from the log
so here is the image so uh here we are
getting the URL of an image
but instead of this string uh let's get
more data of the image such as a width
height
etc for that we have to change the type
of the image
from the content layer dot config.js
file so instead of string just write
image
Let's uh remove this required to
let's save this and check the logs
let's find the image
element
and here it is so uh as you can see
there are multiple uh information that
we are getting from this image type uh
such as a file path relative file path
format height width aspect ratio uh blur
hash data URL Etc so uh for this uh
image we are going to use the uh file
path this one and uh as you know
anything that is in the public folder
can be accessed by just a slash so we
will replace this dot slash public and
just keep this rest URL as it is
so let's add the image make sure you
import this image from the next slash
image
and in the SRC let's write block blog
dot image
Dot
file path
and from this file part we will replace
the dot dot
slash
public string
do
uh nothing
and
let's add
blur in the placeholder or for the more
props of this image component you can
visit the next.js documentation
uh let's add the blur data URL
just write blog dot image Dot
here it is blur hash data URL
so this blur data URL I will get this
blur hash data URL and it will help help
to uh you know load the
blurry effect whenever you load the
website for the first time
and for the alt
let's just use the block title
and let's use fill so that image will
fill out the whole container
let's close this and add the class name
set width to full height to full since
we want to expand the whole image for uh
for the whole div
let's set object position to Center
and set object to cover
set
its radius to rounded uh 2 3 XL
that's it
now inside this article let's add a
class name
set display to Flags Flex direction to
column items start justify at the end
because uh at the end of this whole
component we want to show the block
title Etc
set
margin left and right to 10.
and
set position to relative
height to let's keep
it D5 viewport height
so let's write with to full
and we are getting this whole image
instead of this let's create one more
div
and
and for this do let's give it width to
full and set its display to inline block
and remove this width
let's save this
and now it looks great
now let's add uh overlay on the half
side of this blog so that whenever we
add the you know title like this so it
can be visible
for that for that inside the article
let's create one div and close this div
add a class name
set display to Absolute
top to zero
left
to zero as well
bottom to zero and right to zero Now set
height to full
and
let's add the gradient so uh for that we
will use BG Dash
gradient
to
bottom
and from we will start from the
transparent color
and from
zero percent position
to dark
and let's set its uh radius to rounded
3XL as well
and let's save this
Let's uh add this add index to 0 minus a
dash 10 let's save this
and here is the overlap
now as you can see the uh lower part is
a bit darker than the upper one
let's add the block title
after the image let's create one do
and let's add the class name set width
to full
R for now
set width to three by four
that means width is 75 percent
let's set padding to 16. display Flex
Flex Dash column items
from the start and justify to Center
and let's keep this add index to zero
first let's uh render the category
for that we will use the link element
and inside this lecturer
let's write
first let's open the backtex then write
slash categories
slash
we will add blog dot tags
and let's select the first tag
that's it now close
now close this link and inside this link
Let's uh
add the name of the tag so just copy
this and paste it right here
make sure to import the link from the
next
and let's do let's add the text color to
text dash light let's save it
and here is the category
uh let's uh
add the title
so after this link let's add title in H1
tag so just write blog blog dot title
and after the title let's use a P tag to
add the block description so just write
blog dot description
let's save this
and here it is now uh we are going to
use this category in uh different
components so let's create uh one
separate component for that
so just
go to the components folder
and create one folder called
elements
inside this elements let's create one
file called tag dot Js
let's create the tag component
and let's copy this link
and paste it right here
make sure to import the link
now instead of this href
let me
get the link from the props
let's see if uh no uh nothing is passed
we will use the hash
then the name
and
rest of the props
inside this href
remove this add link
and instead of this blog dot tags just
to write name
and in the class name
let's use the CX
so first we will add the display to
inline Dash block and let's pass props
dot class name if we pass any class name
to this Tech component let's save this
and instead of this link
let's import the
tag component
for the link we will pass this
and for the name we will pass this one
let's remove this
and save it
and here is the link let's style this
let me minimize
go to the tag
now
let's add more class names
set padding top and bottom to three
adding left and right
to 10.
background to dark
and text to light let's save this
all right
let's make it full rounded so just write
down it down date Dash full
capitalize it
increase your font weight to font semi
bold
let's add the Border
border Dash solid and border Dash
light
now let's increase the Border width so
just write powder Dash 2. and it looks
great
let's add the animation on Hover
let's scale it to
let's keep it to one zero five
and add
transition all
ease with duration
and it looks great
that's it now let's uh
add siding for this H1 element
set font way to font dashboard
capitalize
text Dash light
text
Dash
4XL let's save this
all right
let's add H1 tag inside this link
so that whenever someone click on the
log title it will open the blog
uh in the href
let's add the blog link
by using
log dot URL
now in the link let's add one class
let's add margin top to six
and on Hover on of this title Let's uh
add
the effect the underline
for that
let's use the spawn tag so just copy
this add spawn and inside this Pawn add
the blog.title let's add the class name
so first we will use the gradient
so just write BG Dash
gradient
Dash 2 Dash right so gradient to write
from the accent color which is purple
to
accent color
now let's uh change the background size
by just writing BG Dash
length
to 0 pixel and 6 pixel
let's save this actually that should be
underscore between 0 pixel and 6 pixel
now as you can see here
the background size is 0 pixel and 6
pixel now on Hover let's change this
background size so just copy this
paste it right here and instead of 0
pixel Let's uh change it to the 100
percent
let's add BG Dash left Dash bottom
so now this class is for the background
position to left bottom
so this will start animating from the
left
let's add BG no repeat
let's add transition
this time we will not use the all but
instead we will use uh
background size because we are animating
the background of the spawn element
and set the duration to
let's save this
and as you can see it looks much better
now let's uh add The Styling for the
description
set display to inline block margin top
to four
text to text Dash base
Let's uh
text to text Dash large
let's keep it to extra large and font uh
to enter so just write font i n let's
save this and it looks great now uh this
uh this is rendering the first blog and
the first block does not have much data
so instead of that let's render the
another block so just change it this
index from 0 to 1.
and this looks great
let's reduce the overlay
so for that go to right
here
and add the opacity to 90
and now it looks almost the same
now let's uh create this featured post
section
so let's open the components folder
and inside this home
let's add one component called featured
post dot Js
let's create a simple component and
render it inside the page.js file
same as we did for the Home Cover
section
and we are going to pass a blogs same as
this
let's save it
let's get uh
all the logs from the props
and as we did for the Home Cover section
let's use the
short blogs function
make sure you import this function
let's start with the section element
now inside this section let's set width
to full margin top to 16. let's keep it
to 32.
and padding left and right to
32 as well set display to flex
direction to column
items to
Center and justify
to Center as well
now inside the section let's add the H2
element and just write featured post
Let's uh increase the text size
first let's set width to full
set display to inline block and font to
fold
let's capitalize it and set text to for
excel let's save this and check it out
so here is the featured post section
let me close the steps
now in this feature post section we have
two layouts of the blog uh one as this
layout one let's call this layout two
and in the recent post uh in this column
manner we have third layout so let's
create all these layouts
so after this H2 element let's create
one new
and in this still we will use the
display grid
Let's uh keep the grid
calls to two
and grid
Rows 2 2 as well
set cap to 6 and margin top to 16.
now in this table
let's add one article element
here we will use the log layout one
let's add the class to this article
element
uh this article element will use two
columns so write call
sorry it will use one column and two
rows so row spawn
Dash to set the position to relative
let's copy this article and paste it
again for two more times
now uh
uh both of these blocks will cover one
column and one row
so let's just replace this to one and
one is well so this will be layout 2 and
here it is layout 2 as well let's save
this
so this will cover the blog layout one
and here is block layout 2 and 2.
so let's create all the layouts
inside the component let's create one
folder called blog
and inside this blog let's add one
component called log
out one dot shares
let's import
the blog layout one right here
now we will pass the uh
next blog
so in the blog
pass the blog as sorted blocks and in
the arrow blogs uh let's keep the index
to 2.
let's save this
and from the blog layout one
let's deconstruct the blog
let's set set the class name to
inline block
set overflow to Hidden
and rounded
to excel
now inside this do
uh we will use the overlay that we have
already used in the Home Cover section
so just go to the Home Cover section and
copy this overlay
uh
let's copy this whole thing
copy this
and up to the article
and paste it right here now uh in the
image uh
instead of fill let's use height and
width so right width
right log dot image Dot
width and do the same for the height as
well
let's import the tag
let's import the link as well
and we won't be needing the paragraph
tag because we will not display the
description
let's save this uh also let's import the
image first and let's save this
now let's make this absolute
so go here
and remove all these classes
let's set display to Absolute bottom two
zero and padding two
uh let's keep it to 10 and set set index
to 20 let's keep its width to full as
well let's save this
and it looks uh
bit strange
let's change the radius
so rounded 3XL to just Excel
now let's change the color of this text
so in the H1 let's replace it with H2
and instead of text Dash 4XL will keep
it to 2XL
change the
text color to text dash light
let's add margin margin top to four
now let's uh change the style of this
tag as well so let's add the last name
foreign
left and right to let's set it to
six
text to small
ing top and bottom to two
and instead of water Dash 2 set it to
border so it will set the border to one
pixel instead of two now uh this will
override this this class should override
the Border Dash 2 class that we have
defined in the tag component so for that
let's add the important keyword and in
Tailwind you just have to write the
exclamation mark
so it will add the important keyword
let's save this
and looks much better
now let's uh
remove this we don't need it instead let
let's set set index to 10 for this
overlay and for this do let's keep this
at 2 20.
now similar to this let's create a
the blog layout number two
let's save this and
import it right here
just like this
and in the blog let's change the index
number
let's deconstruct the block
now let's use the grid
so grid grid calls to 12
set cap to 4
items to Center and text to dark
so there will be two part one is for the
image and we will add the image inside
this link
so in the link uh let's uh add the blog
dot URL
for the class name
let's
let's add the image
make sure to import it from the next and
import this link as well
and the image SRC
let's copy it from the first layout
just copy this image
and paste it right here
now let's add
[Music]
different classes set aspect ratio
to square
with two full height 2 full object to
cover set object position to Center
so we have 12 columns and this image
will take the four columns so right call
Dash spawn Dash four
and set height to full rounded to Excel
and overflow to Hidden let's save it
and it looks better
now after this link we will add all the
other information
let's copy it from the log layout one
just copy this div
and paste it right here
let's change the class names
set it to cold as 1-8
width to
full now instead of this tag we will use
the spawn element and inside this one
let's add this
tag
let's remove this tag element
now for this one set the text to upper
case
and text color to text Dash accent
font to semi bold
text size text Dash SM
now for the link class let's remove the
margin top 6.
instead add the display to inline block
and set margin top and bottom to one
let's keep the font to
semi bold
and text to
LG
let's remove this classes
and looks better
now for this let's decrease the opacity
so go to the spawn
and in the from accent
add the opacity of 50 do the same for
the two dash excellent
now it looks much better
let's add the date
so after the link add this one inside
this pan we will use the
format function from the date Dash FNS
Library so make sure you import it
now in this function write new date
so we will use a Blog
Dot
published at date
let's add the format of the date
so we want the whole month
date and whole year
let's save it
I think this here should be in small
letters
let's save it
and here it is
let's add the class names
capitalize
set text color to
bit Gray
font to semi bold
and text to base
and looks much better
we can also try the
gray color
well it looks more darker so let's keep
the dark slash 50.
now let's create this recent post
section
copy this
close all
in the home folder create one section
called reset post dot JS and paste it
right here instead of featured post
let's keep the
recent
post
let's remove this this whole div and
instead of featured post just write
recent post
let's remove this import
let's save it and go to the page.js file
and let's import the recent post
make sure you pass the Vlog as well
let's check it out
so here is the recent post
now here uh with the recent post title
we have this view all uh link that uh
goes to the slash category slash all
let's add this and add all these blogs
let's copy this create one div and paste
a H2 element along with the link
set href to slash categories
slash all
and right view all
in the class name
let's add
display to inline block
font to
medium text color to text accent
underline
and underline offset 2.
to
and set text to text Dash LG
now in this div let's add the display to
flex width to full and justify to space
between
let's import this link
let's remove this with full
save it
and it looks much better
after this leave
let's create one more dough
in this day we will use the display grid
and set grid
calls to 3 set Gap to
16 and margin top to 16 as well
now in this div let's display all blocks
so
we will display only six blocks so we
have already displayed four blogs so we
are left with the rest of the blogs
so let's use the sorted blocks
dot slice now uh the first Vlog was the
block dash one and after that we have
displayed four blog so we will slice
this array from 5 to 11 to get the uh
five uh sorry six blocks
so dot map so this last method will give
us the
5 6 7 8 9 and 10th block slice method
will not consider this last boundary
let's use map
get the plug and index
let's return the article
and here we will use the blog layout
three
let's add the class name to this article
element
set cold spawn dash one and row that's
fun dash one as well
and set the position to relative
Also let's add the
rows as well
so three rows
and save it
so we have one two and three four five
and six blocks
let's create the third layout
let's add blog layout
three dot Js
let's save it
and import this right here
make sure to import it
in the blog
let's pass the log element
let's deconstruct the blog
now this layout will be almost the same
as the layout too so let's go to the
layout 2.
copy the whole thing and paste it right
here just change the names
and let's uh change some classes
so now uh let's not use the grid
instead we will use flex Flex Dash
column items to Center
now let's remove this call spawn-4
keep everything as it is
let's change this aspect Square
two four by three
and after in this do let's remove this
and set Flex to flex Dash call
with two full and margin top to four
let's save this
and it looks much better
now as you can see this header is
going under this blogs so let's add the
set index
go to the header
now in this header element let's go to
this new
set Z to 50
and it looks much better now
let's add the hover animation
let's go to block layout 3 and in this
image
first let's add one class called group
right here
and
and this image
let's write group Dash hover we'll scale
this image to 105
set
transition
to all is and
duration to
300 let's save this
and looks much better
now for this one
Let's uh
add the group over instead of just hover
so in the spawn
let's add the group Dash over
now it looks much better
let's do the same for this elements as
well
copy
this
copy this
and open the layout to
add in the image at the
group class
and let's add group Dash hover in this
part
and it looks great
let's do the same for the layout one as
well
close all this open layout one
add the image
let's add the
group class
and group Dash hover
let's add cursor
to pointer for the image
and this looks much better
looks great let's compare this with
the
demo
I think we have to add a little bit
padding here
go to the header
so we have MR2 MX2 let's add the MX2
instead of MR2
and looks almost same
now let's add the footer
now same as we did for the header let's
create
one more folder called
footer and add
index.js file
let's name it as footer
let's save it and import it in the
layout
after this
children component
so here is the footer
now let's
use the footer element
inside this footer let's add text in the
H3 and another text in the
paragraph
now go to the project files and open
this website content.txt file here you
will find the text for the footer copy
this paste it right here
and copy this paste in the paragraph tag
so after the paragraph We have one form
now for this form we are going to use
the reactor hook form
so let's go to that website react hook
form
open this website
now react to form as mentioned here is a
performance flexible and extensible
forms with easy to use validations so
this is really create Library if you are
dealing with forms in react
for now just go to the tools and click
on this form Builder
and let's see how many fields we will
require so for this we will only
required input and this submit button
so let's delete all the other fields
let's edit this it's not the first name
it is an email
and type select it to email
if you want any other validations you
can write it from here let's update
and here is the code
first let's copy this and import it
right here
copy the form
and after this paragraph tag
and copy
all this
and paste it right here
for now let's
save this and check it out
so as mentioned here here create context
only works in client components
so we have to make it as a client
component and to convert any server
component to client component we just
have to use this use client
and save it
so here are all the text and the form
let me just type anything code box at
gmail.com
let's click on the submit let's check
the log so we are getting the object
and this object will contain the email
first let's style this and then we will
see how this form is working
I had class to footer
set margin
top
to
16.
rounded to 2XL VG dark
margin to
then
Flex Flex direction to column items
Center
text light
let's save this
now for the H3
let's add margin top to 16 font
medium text to
Center capitalize and text size to 4
Excel padding left and right to four
save it
and looks great
now for the paragraph tag
let's set margin top to 5 pairing left
and right to 4 text to Center width to
full let's set width two three by five
font to
light
set text size to base
looks better
now for the form
let's add the class name
set
is in top to six
let's set minimum width
to at least
384 pixel
set display to Flags items to
stretch
VG to light
padding Dash 2
set rounded
and margin left and right to 4.
let's save it
and looks much better
now let's use the Tailwinds form plugin
for that let's open the railway in CSS
plugins
let's scroll down
click on this forms
so we have already downloaded this forms
plugin we just have to add it in the
tailwind.config.js file so copy this
open the Tailwind
and in the plugins
let's add it
let's save this
so this will apply the basic
style to this form
that is uh
let's add class to this input
let's set width to full
set background to transparent
set text to dark
now on Focus
we want the border to be dark
and on Focus
set ring to zero we don't want any
border
now
set border to zero and set border to
bottom which is only want the bottom
border set margin right to
padding bottom to one
and let's save this
and it looks better
let's change this placeholder to enter
your email
let's save it
and add the glass for the submit button
right down to the dark
text to light
cursor to
pointer
font cited to medium
rounded
pairing left and right to Phi padding
top and bottom to one
and let's save this
and it looks much better
so let me tell you how this form works
first let's see what is this use form
hook so this use form Hook is to manage
the forms uh and it gives us different
uh functions and values such as a
register now this register method allows
you to register an input or select an
element and apply different valuation
Rules to This input like this we have
used register method to register the
email input and here are some validation
rules
now next is the handle submit method
now this function will receive the form
data a form validation is successful now
this form state is an object that
contains information about the entire
form such as errors and it also gives us
different values such as is loading or
is submitting it's submitted Etc so that
you can create interactive forms and
this is simple on submit
function
that gives us the data now as you can
see here this handle submit function
will take the under on submit function
so once the validation is done then it
will call this function and Returns the
data so there are lots of function in
this react hook form then we are
currently using but I suggest you to go
to the API and check all this different
functions and methods
let's add the social media links for
that let's go to the header
and let's copy this whole div
and paste it after the form
so in this do let's add the class name
set display to flex items to Center and
margin top to eight
let's save it
we have to import all these icons
let's import it
import LinkedIn
Twitter icon
GitHub icon and
triple icon
so here are all the icons let's change
the color of this GitHub let's add
one more class called
fill
dash light
and now it looks much better
now after this do let's add one more
dough
add one more spawn
right
Ampersand copy for the copy symbol go to
the website content
and copy this
paste here
let's use the link
set href to slash sitemap dot XML
and write
sitemap dot XML
after this link add one more div
and right made
with
right Ampersand hearts
bye let's use the finger tag and inside
this anchor title
let's write code box
for now let's add the link of my blog
website called Dave dreaming.com
let's save this
and here it is
so in this do let's add the class name
set with to full margin top two
uh 32 or let's say
position to relative font to medium
let's set the powder
top
border Dash solid and Border color to
border dash light
set padding left and right two
sorry top and bottom two six
running left and right to eight
set display to flex Flex Direction too
row
items to
Center
and justify
face between
let's save it
now for this this one
let's
use text Dash Center and for this link
let's add the class name
set text Dash Center underline and
that's it
for the still let's add class name text
Dash Center
in the anchor tag
let's keep the underline
and that's it
let's remove this padding left
so just write opening left to zero
and this input
and now it looks much better
let's remove this extra white space
open the
recent post
so instead of this three by three grid
let's write
three by two let's save this
now it looks much
better
so our homepage is completed now let's
uh create this blog page
let me close all this
close this as well
thank you
let's open the blog page
now in this URL as you can see
there is slash blog and slash blog title
Now to create a such URL and to create
uh all the pages for all the blogs we
are going to use the dynamic routing so
let's write Dynamic routing next Js
click on this Dynamic routes
make sure you are in the app router
now as mentioned here Dynamic segment
can be created by wrapping a folder's
name in square brackets for example ID
or slug so Dynamic segments are passed
as the params prop to layout page route
and generate metadata functions so let's
see how this works
let's open the
app folder
and inside this app folder create one
more folder called vlogs
and inside the blogs let's create one
more folder called slug for the blog
slug
now inside the slug create one more file
called page dot Js
now uh whatever we passed after this URL
so slash blog slash Blog name this Blog
name will be passed as a slug to this
page.js file and we will use the use
that slug to display uh the data for
that particular block
so let's see how we can get this log go
to this documentation and let's copy
this
instead of page let's just write blog
page
and remove this part
and let's save this
open the website click on this blog
as you can see in the my post it will
give us the slug
which says building Progressive web apps
bringing the gap between web and mobile
so it is same as this part of the URL
let's click on the another blog
and here is the same as the URL
so let's see how we can use this lug to
render the blog so in this blog page
let's get the log
first let's import the all blocks from
the content layer slash generated
so all blogs
dot find
let's pass each block
and
let's compare it with vlog
dot underscore Raw
dot flat in path
which will be the URL
is equal to the
params dot slug
let's see this flattened path go to the
CMD
and here you can see the flattened path
is the slug of the blog
now uh how this
is this going to be the slug of the
block because
this is the file name for this
particular blog
open the content folder and as you can
see all these file names are working as
the slug so make sure that this file
names are unique and not the same
so this will give us the blog uh that
has this same slug as the flattened path
now let's
render this blog
add the article element
let's add one more div and this div we
will add the tag
make sure to import this tag component
and the tag name let's
add the tag so blog dot tags
first element
then link
add vectrix
slash categories
slash
long
dot tags
and 0.
let's add the
class name as well
set padding left and right to six
text to small
and padding top and bottom two two
let's close this tag
so after this tag let's add the H1
element which contains the blog
dot title
let's add class name
set display to
inline block
margin top
two six point semi bold
capitalize
text
dash light
text size to 5 XL
leading
to normal
leading that means the line height
set position to relative and width to
let's keep it as 5 by 6.
so it does not span the whole uh area
let's save this
so we have this H1 tag right here
let's add all the other classes
so in this first day we have text but in
the second view let's add the image
add one do
and let's add the class name
now this uh will be the absolute one so
write position to Absolute
top 0 left
0 right 0
bottom 0 as well height to pull
PG dark slash 6C opacity
and inside this do let's add the image
for image you can use layout to
copy this whole image and paste it right
here
make sure to import the image from next
slash image
we don't need any animation here
that's it let's save it
let's decrease its height
so let's uh
go to the first div and add the classes
set margin bottom to 8
text to Center relative width to full
and height to
70 VH
set VG to dark let's save it
and it looks much better
now for the second deal let's add the
class name
set width to full set index to 10
display Flex Flex direction to column
items two
Center
justify to Center as well
and set absolute
and let's set it to the center so top
dash 1 by 2 left dash 1 by 2 that means
left 50 percent
and negative translate X to 1 by 2 and
negative Translate Y
2 1 by 2 as well
let's save this
as you can see this div is in the center
as well
let's check for the other blocks as well
and it looks great
actually we have to close this div
because it will work as an overlay let's
delete this and save this
and now it looks much better
let's add this block details
so in the blog folder create one
component called log details dot Js
now this blog details will have blog
slug
let's import it right after this do
pass the blog
and the slug as well
let's remove this
and add
time
so inside this time element we will
render the date
so just write format make sure to import
this function from date Dash FNS Library
and use parse ISO
add blog dot published
published
[Music]
at
and for the format
let's format it
right l
D for the date and Y for the year
let's import this blog details
and we have to pass slug as params.slug
so here is the date
now next is the view
so for now let's just write spawn and
just write 10 views
next
let's add one more do
to add the reading time
now we have to compute compute this
reading Time by using the library called
reading dash time which we already have
installed right here
so let's go to the contentlayer.config
in the computed Fields after the URL
let's add reading time
and set its type to Json
and let's use the resolve this function
will give us the dock
and let's call reading time function
from the reading dash time Library
and in this function we will pass the
talk dot body
dot dot Raw
let's save this
and check it out
let me just lock this blog
now if you check right here that is this
reading time so it has different format
it has text which says 10 minutes read
in minutes in time and in words so there
are
1882 words
so let's render this so just write blog
dot reading
time dot text
and after this do
let's use the link element
this will link to
slash categories
slash
log
dot slug
zero
let's close this link
and use this
variable
let's add hash before this
let's add
class name set margin to 3
let's do the same for
this div as well
this Pawn
and for the time
now for this div
and let's set padding left and right to
dash 10 background to Accent color text
to light
padding top and bottom to two display
Flex items
Center justify space around
Flex
wrap
and text size to extra large font
medium
and set margin left and right to Phi
let's set it to 10 let's make it rounded
up to LG
now it should be
tags not slug
let's save this
and looks much better
so after this uh block details we have
two elements one is the table of content
and another is the blog details
so let's render them
so after the blog details let's create
one more div
let's add the class name set display to
grid grid calls to 12.
set cap to
16 margin top two
eight and padding left and right to 10.
so next one is the div for the table of
content
let's use the
call spawn
Dash 4
and another do
for the log details this will use
correspond Dash 8
let's create another component to render
the block details so inside the blog
folder create one component called
render
MDX dot Js
let's
import this MDX component
let's remove this and instead we will
render this component so this component
will
use the blog prop
so make sure you pass the blog let's
save this
and deconstruct the block from here
and as we have seen
right here we'll use this use MDX
component
copy this
paste it right here
copy this as well
and copy this
let's save this
and check it
we have yet to import this
it should be blog not the post
let's check this
all right
I think we are not getting the
uh blog.body.code
let me check the content layout.config
I think uh there is one more field that
we have to add that is called the
content type
now let's set it to MDX
let's save this
all right now in this blogs I have used
the Nexus image so it is uh telling me
that there is no image component is
imported so let's uh go to the
render.mdx
and let's create
one uh variable
called MDX components
and here we will add the image component
let's pass this as
the components inside this MDX content
make sure you import the image
from the next Js
let's save this
now it says cannot access image.prop
Types on server so we have to convert
this component into a client component
so let's use use client
let's save this
and as you can see it is rendering this
uh log details
let's add the class to this div
set call
spawn two eight
and font to enter
let's save this
as you can see we are getting all this
content
so how we can style this so for that we
have to open the Italian CSS plugins
again
go to this typography plugin
and we have already installed it so
let's import this in the tailwind.config
file
let's save this
now uh let's apply the class name
now in here
uh as I mentioned here we can use the
pros classes to add sensible typography
styles to any vanilla HTML so we have to
write just prose class
so let's just write pros and Save
and here it is it will apply all the
necessary classes to the block elements
H1 tags H2 tags Etc
and by just adding one class it looks
really great
now let's set its width
to full
and also increase the pros class to Pros
Dash LG let's save this
now it will increase the font uh size
let's set width to Max
so max with to Max content
and now it looks much better
now still there is some format is
required so for that you can visit this
website and
and there are multiple classes available
multiple themes you can use
now if you want to change any element
we can use this class let's say you want
to change the style of the H1 element
then you can use Pros Dash H1 class so
let's use it for the block code so just
copy
this
and paste it right here
now for this block code I want to change
its background
to purple and set opacity to 20
let's save this
and as you can see in this block code
element
that is purple in the background let's
add the
padding
set clock or padding two two
and padding left and right two
six let's save this
looks much better
now let's change the Border color of
this block code element
to border Dash accent
and now it looks much better
Also let's make this uh normal fonts
instead of this italic
so in the block code
changed to not
italic class
and this looks much better
foreign
for that you can use
rounded
for the right side to LG so this will
add the powdered top right radius to 0.5
RAM and Border bottom right radius to
0.5 M as well
now as you can see both of these Corners
are rounded
let's change the color of this Ally
markers
for that you can use froze Dash Ally
and use the marker
change the color to text Dash accent
and now it looks great
now this is the table but it is not
formatted well
so for this we have to add a remark and
re-hype plugins so what is remark and
re-hype so remark is a markdown
processor while the G hype is an HTML
processor so let's see which plugins we
are going to use
but before that let's uh go to this
documentation and click on the make
source
and click the MDX
now here we can add different plugins
for the rehype and remark as well
so let's open the content layer
go right here type MDX
and let's add the
remark plugin
and inside this array
let's add remark gfm make sure you
import remark gfm from remark gfm let's
save this
and check this blog now we can see this
table and very formatted way
so how this happened let's check what is
remark gfm
let's click on this link
now let's scroll to the Bottom now as
mentioned here this remark plugin is
support the gfm that means the it
supports Auto Link literals footnotes
strikethrough tables task list Etc that
are written in the markdown files like
as you can see in this example uh for
footnotes you can write like this
and for the strikethrough you can use
this till this
this is the table format in the markdown
and this is the task list
now let's uh add the rehire plugins
let's add re-hype plugins
and in here
first we will use the re-high slug
so let's see what is this and make sure
you import this rehive slug from this
rehype Dash slug
let's open this
so this rehab plugin adds an IDs to the
headings
so let's open the inspect element
click on any heading
as you can see there is an ID
about this plugin now we will use this
ID to Target this heading
now let's add one more plugin
this plugin called
V hype Auto Link headings
make sure you import it
like this Import rehive Auto Link
headings from rehab Auto Link headings
let me remove this let's save this
and let's uh check this heading again
now as you can see here inside this H3
there is a link
and in this link there is an href that
that is the ID of this element so uh
this plugin will create a automatic
links to to The Heading so let's say
we go to the
URL and add this ID and press enter so
it will scroll down to this heading so
whenever you want to share this blog or
part of this blog too and even you can
share this URL so this will start from
this heading
let's see more details about this plugin
let's see the options
so uh we have different type of behavior
option in prepend it will inject the
link before the heading text a pen will
inject the link after the heading text
wrap will wrap the whole heading text
and before and after will insert the
link before the heading or after the
heading so we will use the append
Behavior so to add this option go to the
content layer
let's import
this in an array and let's create one
empty object
let's add the
Behavior option and set its value to
append
let's save this
and
check this heading element
now here is the link after the heading
text now let's add smaller hash for this
so this link has a spawn element and it
has icon space icon Dash link last names
so let's open the
global.css file
first let's set the HTML scroll Behavior
to smooth
then let's use H1
to link
to dot icon
dot icon Dash link
so we are going to Target this spawn
element
now let's use the
V4 sudo class
we're going to do this for the H1 H2 H3
that's it
let's write H2 H3
and add the content
to hash
and font size to
0.8 Ram
let's save this
now as you can see there is this small
hash for each H1 H2 and H3 tags
on click on this it will scroll to this
element
and also it will change the ID
of this URL now let's remove this
underline
for that we have to do
H2
a link then H3
a link
and set text decoration
to none
let's add
important keyword
and now it looks great
now let's see uh
how to add different code themes for
this code blocks
so let's uh open the
free hype
pretty code
go to this website
now as mentioned here rehi pretty code
is a rehi plugin powered by the Shiki
syntax highlighter that provides
beautiful code blocks for markdown or
MDX and it's fast since it avoids
runtime syntax highlighting by executing
it build time
so this is a really good plugin to
highlight the code syntax
let's see how we can use it
so go to the installation we have
already installed this plugin and the
Shiki syntax highlighter as well and
let's use this go to the content layer
and here
let's use this
foreign
pretty code
and
let's write code options
so just write const code options
and inside this code options we will
pass the theme
let's see the options
so we have theme option
so the default theme is GitHub dark
dimmed and Shiki has a bunch of
pre-packaged theme which can be
specified as plain text let's go to this
pre-pack themes
so here are all the themes that you can
use you just have to write in the plain
text so we will use the GitHub theme so
which is
right here GitHub Dash dark
so just write GitHub Dash dark let's
save this
and as you can see uh now it has a color
now there are a lot of options that you
can use such as Showing Line highlighted
lines
are line numbers or word highlighting
inline code highlighting
let's use this now as mentioned here CSS
counter can be used to add line numbers
so let's copy this and paste it inside
the
global.css file
let's save this
now to show the line numbers on the blog
we have to add an option
now to show the line numbers we have to
add an option like this
let's open
right
here now as you can see there are line
numbers let's open this part in the
markdown file so we are in the building
process Progressive web apps blog
go to the content and open
building Progressive web apps
let's go to the code part so this is the
code so I just have to add the show line
numbers right here
now let's say if we want to highlight
any line
let's check out
so highlight any specific line so this
should highlight line one two three and
fourth
let's add this option let's save this
and that is nothing because we have to
add the CSS
let's open the inspect element
click on this line one
now as you can see uh in the first four
line there is one data attribute called
Data Dash highlighted dash line so for
that we have to add the CSS
so let's go to the global dot css4 file
and after this
let's add this attribute
and add the required styling so for the
background color
I will use rgba
2.55255255 and set the opacity to point
one
and add the important keyword let's save
this
now as you can see uh background color
is changed for this four lines
Let's uh add the padding
to 2 pixel
padding left to zero
padding
right
to 4 pixel
and
border radius
to 2 pixel
let's add
bottle left so border
left
to 2 pixel solid and let's copy the
accent color from Tailwind config
copy this and paste it right here
let's save this
and as you can see
there is this
accent color on the left
now let's see uh how we can highlight
the characters for that we have to use
just slash
let's go to the blog
let's highlight this signs
let's highlight this science word
save this
and
let's check this one
now as you can see in the inside the
spawn element there is new attribute
called Data Dash highlighted Dash
characters so let's copy this attribute
and add the styling
now let's increase the opacity
to
do
pairing to 2 pixel
and Border Radius 2 2 pixel as well
let's save this
and as you can see it is highlighted
now let's see what other features it has
it has group highlighted characters by
ID
highlighting inline code
it also has the titles
let's add the title
let's go to
this
let's add the title
let's keep it as
index dot HTML and let's save this
now here is the title of this code block
let's style this before that
let's get its attribute which is right
here data dash rehype dash pretty code
title
so let's go to the global.css file
and let's style this
set position to
absolute
right zero
background color
to the accent color
set text color to
White
padding
to 4 pixel from the top
eight from the left
and right
font size to 1 Ram
and border and
start radius to 4 pixel let me show this
to you
so here is the title it is not exactly
at the right position so let's
open the
code block element
so in this div we have one uh data
attribute called Data rehab critical
fragment so let's add relative position
to this attribute
before this let's add the data attribute
set position to
relative let's save this
now as you can see this title is inside
the code block and it looks great
now let's see what next we have the
caption
so let's style this as well go to the
blog and add caption
so
this file contains HTML code
let's save this
here is the caption
let's get the data attribute for this
caption which is right here
and let's style this
set the position to Absolute
top to 100 percent
width to 100 as well
text align
Center
font size 2.
and let's set its color to gray so it is
7 4 7 4 7 4 let's save this
and looks much better
that's it so this rehype pretty code has
a lot of features that you can show such
as highlight title you can change the
language as well and show the line
numbers and this caption as well
so this is pretty good for your blog
let's close this
so I think uh this block part is almost
completed let's see how we can create
the table of content component
now let's check this Toc component from
this blog now in this table of contents
we have different labels of this heading
elements so this one is the H1 but this
is the H2 now H2 is the subheading of
this H1 so it is uh
as the child of this H1 tag same for
this
now on click on this it will uh it will
scroll the page to that certain heading
because of this ID
which is uh in this link now uh we are
using the content layer and the
structure of content layer is a bit
different so we are going to use
computed field to compute the whole
table of contents and for that I found a
really good solution from one of the
blog so let me share that link with you
right table of content from content
layer and this one
is the link which is by Yusuf
and the solution is really great so
let's implement this
for now we don't require this blog let
me close all these tabs
now let's go to the
content layer let's close all this
open the content layer dot config.js
file
and right here
after the reading time let's write the
TOC
let's keep its type to Json and let's
change this resolve function
let's make it async
for now let's return
true
now let's uh check how this headings
looks in the Raw format
so if you check right here what if we
stack headings so uh this uses the two
hash that means this is the H2 element
and this heading uses the three hash
that means it should be the H3 element
so from this whole raw data we have to
extract such headings now there is a
common pattern between these headings
such as it can have hasher hashes space
or new line characters
Etc so for that we are going to
construct the our regular expression
so let me
do that
create
const
regular EXP
and let's start with the slash first
let's do this for the
new line
let me write the whole regular
expression then I will explain each each
and every part of that expression
so let me explain this a regular
expression
now this slash it marks the beginning of
the expression and slash n which matches
the new line
and now this bracket
is the named capturing group named Flag
where it matches the hash character
and this one to six that means it
specifies that there should be between 1
and 6 hash characters uh now same as
this flag this is also another name
capturing group called content at the
DOT
matches any character except the new
line and plus specifies that there
should be at least one or more
characters so this is at the end of the
exploration
and in between this name capturing
groups we have a slash S backslash s
that matches one or more white space
characters
so let's see if this regular expression
can grab this type of content
so let me just copy
it's from here up to this
and let's go to the browser
let me open a new tab
and in the console first let's uh create
one variable called post
and paste all the strings
now in the post as you can see here is
the whole string now let's uh try to use
the regular expression to grab this
headings
so let's use post dot match
first let's
declare the regular expiration
paste it right here now let's write post
dot match all
sorry post dot match
all and inside this
function let's pass the
regular expression
so we got this iterator let's use the
array
let's use array
Dot from
this iterator
and now we got array within two elements
so first element contains the
content that we got using this regular
expression and that is this groups
and in this group there is flag
it has two hashes and in the content we
got the content of the uh of the heading
and in the next element
we have three hashes inside this group
and the content for the third H3 heading
as well so this is how we will capture
the groups for each heading
and then we will decide the depth of
this heading
so let me close this
Let's uh Define the
headings
array
Dot from
post dot body dot Raw
dot match
all
with this regular expression
and then we will use the map
now inside this map we will
deconstruct the groups from this array
first let's uh get the flag value from
the group
dot flag
now this question mark is an operator
which checks if group exists and if it
exists then it will check the flag value
do the same for the content group
and let's return
first we will return the label so if
there is
flag
then
check the length of the flag
if it is one
then it should be the one label
if the
flag dot length is 2 then it should be
two
else it should be three so this will uh
create the table of content for H1 H2
and H3 tags
now for the text set the content
and for this log
let's use the GitHub Slugger to generate
this log from the content
for that we have to import it
so import
GitHub
Slugger
from
GitHub Dash Slugger
now to use this
first
let's define it right here right cons
Slugger equal to new GitHub Slugger
and let's create this log from this
content so use
Slugger dot Slug and pass the content
now before that let's uh put a condition
if there is content then create this log
else it should be undefined
so that's it it Returns the
headings
now instead of this post
let's use the dock let's save this
now we got an error it says group is not
defined
let's say it should be
groups let's save this
and here is the TOC component as you can
see there are different heading with the
label such as 2 3
2 3 1
Etc so let's uh see how we can render
this Toc
so open the block page
we will use the details HTML tag
now in this details
let's use this summary to show the table
of content heading
after the summary
let's use another list
and let's uh map the blog
dot doc
dot map
so here we are getting heading so let's
get the heading
now we will return the
Ally element
in this alloy element let's use the
anchor tag
in the anchor tag let's add one span
and this one right
heading dot text
and in the href
let's add the ID
so add back text
hash
then use a currency sign and brackets to
add heading
dot slug
let's save this
now as you can see we have all the
headings listed here
let's go to this and it's working great
uh now let's see how we can style this
first let's add the class name to this
details
set border to one pixel
order solid border dark
set text to dark
rounded to LG
pairing two four
keep it sticky
and top to six Let's uh set max height
to
80 VH
overflow
hidden
and overflow y
to
Auto
Also let's keep this table of content to
open so in the details uh element just
write open prop
let's add class for the summary
set text size to text LG font to semi
bold
capitalize
and set cursor to pointer
let's save this
and it looks much better
now for the UL let's add class name
set margin top to 4 font two enter
text to base
now in the alignments let's
add the key first
write back text then hash
then inside the braces right heading
dot slug
and add class name set py finding top
and bottom to one
and looks much better
now let's uh use the data attribute to
style uh different depth of this
headings
so just write data Dash label
and write heading dot level
let's add the class name now if data
Dash label
equal to 2
then
set the padding left to
0 if data dash level 2
then set pairing top to two if data
label are equal to 2 then set the Border
top
HD
let's add border solid
border Dash dark to
40. let's save this
now as you can see uh it will uh create
Parts between the uh whole uh headings
so now if data label
is three
then set padding left to 4 let's save
this
now as you can see that is space on the
left of this child label headings
let's add more space up to six
and display Flex items to Center and
justify to start let's save this
and it looks much better
now let's see how we can add this dots
let's put condition before the spawn
element if heading Dot
level
is equal to
then
add one span element
else display null
so inside the spawn just write Ampersand
and PSP this will add one
this will add one space
and in the class name write flags with
to 1 High 2 1 rounded to full and BG 2
dark
set margin right to two let's save this
and now it looks much great
now let's uh underline this heading on
Hover for that go to the spawn and class
name
on Hover set underline
and this looks great
so this blog page is completed now let's
create the pages for the categories
now uh same as the slash blog we will
create the dynamic routes for the slash
categories so for that uh go to the
app folder and create one more folder
called categories
inside this category
let's add one more folder called slug
now in the slug
let's create the page dot JS file
so now
let's create the const category page
and here we will get the params
which stands for the parameters
and let's return the
category name
here it is
parents dot slug
so let's save this
and click on this link
fold export is not react component let's
export this
export
default
category page
so here we have web development category
now uh there is this space so
let's check this out
now if you see in this link
there is a space in the category so we
have to slugify this category as well so
go to the
blog page
and here is the tag so go to the tag
here we are using the link passed from
the prop so we have to modify this link
we can use slug
from the GitHub Slugger
and just
pass the blog dot tags
copy this paste here
let's not paste here
just keep it in the link
so now it is web Dash development Let's
uh check for the home component
there is also space so we have to do
this
for the
Home Cover section
make sure you import this lug from the
GitHub Dash Slugger
and we have this in the log layout one
log layout one
let's paste this
now in this Vlog there is also another
tag right here let's change it as well
let's open the log details
let's change
this
and make sure you import the
slug
actually there is similar names so let's
change this to log slug
let's save this
and it is working
so let's click on this web Dash
development it will give us the category
name
so let's see how to render the category
name and all the list of categories
along with the blogs
go to the
categories page.js file
now here first let's get all the
categories available so create one
variable call all
categories
equal to an array that contains one
category called all that will uh display
all the blogs
and let's
get all the blogs
all blogs dot filter
so let's get individual blog
and let's return
a Blog
right
dot tags
dot sum
and for some tag
first we will slugify the tag so just
write cons logified
equal to slug
tag
then if
all categories
does not include
sluggify tag
then we will push this slugify tag to
this all categories array so all
categories dot push
this sluggified
tag now if params Dot slug is
all
then return to for all the blogs so uh
it will return it will filter all the
blogs
else return sluggified
equal to parents dot slug so let me
explain this again so uh we want to
filter all the blogs as per the
params.log and also we want to create
the array
for all the categories so here uh in all
blogs first we will filter each blog and
uh for each tag uh we will use this some
function
now uh for each tag we will uh first we
will slugify this tag using the slug
function and then we will see if this
sluggify tag is already in the all
categories Aries or not if it is not
then we will push it and if the
params.slug equal to all then let's
return true
else we will return sluggified equal to
penance.log so let's say if the Penance
dot slug is web development and
slugified uh tag is also web development
so it will filter all the blogs that has
the web development tag
so uh the process is same for all the uh
tags except the all now for the all it
will return true so it will display all
blocks
that's it
so let's create
an article
tag
and inside this article let's create one
do this day will contain H1 tag
with the
params
dot slug that represents the category
name
and after the H1 there is one spawn tag
that will display the text called
discover
more
categories
and X1
your
knowledge
now after this do
we will display all the categories
so for that let's uh create one
component called categories inside this
blog folder create get a
queries.js
let's import this component right here
and also pass the categories
so pass the all categories as a prop
now also create one more prop called
active
which you which will have the current
slug
make sure to import this
let's deconstruct the categories
and
active
so let's uh keep this device as it is
inside this div
uh we will render the category
now let's create an individual component
for the category as well same as we did
for the tag so just copy this
and inside the blog create one more
component called category dot JS paste
it instead of tag let's change its name
to category that is uh one thing that we
will add
which is the active prop
now let's uh add one class
so now let's add one
conditional class name so when active
the background should be dark
text should be light
otherwise
the background should be light and text
should be dark
remove the background from here and
text color as well let's save this for
now
and inside the categories let's import
it so let's map the categories dot map
so we have category
which will return this component
first let's write the key
then link
use backticks slash get a curries
slash
cat
then for the name
pass the get and for the active now here
we will check uh
to match the current uh Slug and the
this category
now let's add the active
let's change its name from active to
let's just write current slug
save it and let's change it here as well
so let's uh compare so current slog it
should be equal to
sluggified
category so if this matches it will
change the style of the active category
otherwise it will keep all the category
as the same let's uh
save this
category is not defined let's define it
so here are all the categories Let's uh
change its style in the categories view
let's add the class names set pairing
left and right to
20 margin top 2. 10
border top to two text dark
border bottom to two
border solid and border
color to dark
let's set pairing top and bottom to four
display Flex items
start Flex wrap
and font to medium
set margin left and right to 10. let's
save this
and it looks better
let's add The Styling for this category
let's change
this py2 to let's change the Border
color to border Dash dark
let's save this
let's add margin M Dash 2
let's open the category pages and
compare it
looks
great
let's not capitalize and add the hash
now it looks much better
so as you can see here it is changing
the URL
let's add The Styling for this
foreign
set margin top
to
12 display
S Flex direction to column text Dash
dark
now for this blue
let's set padding left and right to 10.
let's set it to 32 display Flex Flex
direction to column
now for this H1
set margin top to six
font to semi bold
text to
Phi XL
let's save this
and it looks great
now for this Pawn element
let's add margin top to 2
and set display to inline block
now it looks much better
Let's uh let's change the font weight
from font semi bold
to font Dash medium
or let's just keep the
font as it is font Dash normal
now it looks much better
now let's uh render this blogs as per
the uh category name
so after this category create one div
and Let's do let's add the display to
grid
calls to to
let's set it to three let's set grid
rows to two
set cap to
and set margin top
to
set padding left and right to 32.
now in here let's map the blocks
so blogs.map
blog and index
return the
article element
and inside this article let's use the
log layout
make sure you pass the
blog
in the article let's add the class name
to call that spawn
dash one call Dash
sorry row Dash spawn
dash one and set the position to
relative
also don't forget to add the key
let's save this
and
is displaying all the blogs
let's go to the productivity code
quality CSS
web development
JavaScript
and it looks much better
now let's uh delete this block one
so go to the
content and there it is block dash one
now it looks much better
so the categories page is completed now
let's create the about page
now before we create about and contact
page I want to uh show you something uh
let's check this generate static params
function
from the next.js documentation
now as mentioned here the general static
params function can be used in
combination with Dynamic route or
segments to statically generate routes
at a build time instead of on-demand at
request time so uh in our blog we have
static data so there is no need to
generate any page on demand we can
statically generate all these routes so
it is better to use this function so
let's copy this
and go to the
categories page
and before this page let's paste this
function now uh
this function generates uh different
routes as per this log that you pass
right here
so let's remove this
now let's create
one more one array called
categories
and one array called paths
now path will have one params
with slug all
now
from the all blogs
Let's uh map each blog
now for each block let's put a condition
if
block dot is published is true then
we will check the uh tags for the blogs
so write blog dot text Dot map
for each tag
let's slugify the tag
now here we will use the Slugger so let
me just open its documentation
now instead of using slug directly we
should use uh like this because this way
uh the Slugger will uh keep an eye on
each slug so uh there is no same slug
generated so let's uh use this
import the GitHub Slugger
then we will use Slugger Dot
slug
inside this log let's pass the tag
now uh we will check if categories does
not include
the sluggify tag
if it does not include it and
let's push it
now this logic is almost same as we done
here
but instead we we will return the paths
from this function
so paths dot push
arms
slug
sluggified let's replace this to slug
all and instead of this let's return the
paths so this will eventually generate
routes for each slug such as all web
development Etc so if you have a static
data in your website then it is better
to use the generic generator setting
params function to generate the all the
roots at a build time so it will load
the website much more faster
so let's do the same uh for the blogs as
well let's copy this function open the
blogs
page
and here let's paste it
now here we just have to use this
inside the return paste this
and inside of fine we will use the map
function
copy this
and here
we will return the
slug with the
this value now in the categories
actually
we should just pass the slug
not the paramps
so let's remove this
and this as well so let's save this
now we are on the development server so
for the development server it will
always create the on-demand request but
whenever we build our website it will
create all the routes and then sell the
website more faster
that's it now let's create the about
page
open the
app folder
create one more folder
called the about
and inside this about folder create one
file called page dot JS let's create the
function
export default function
called about
this will return let's use the fragments
about details
now in this about page first uh
let's Design This cover page
so and the components folder create one
more folder called about
here let's create one file called about
cover section dot Js
let's import this
make sure to import
this one this component
let's add a section element set class
names set with to full
and height to
75 VH
set border Dash bottom two
powder solid
and Border color to dark
set display to flex Flex direction to
column
let's skip Row for the desktop size and
set items
to Center
so I'll justify to Center as well
set text color to text Dash dark
now after this section element Let's uh
add one div
this day will contain one image
let's use the SRC
Alt
now for this image
I have generated this using the binge
search
and daily 2 so you can generate a
different image you like
for now let's use this
go to the project files and here is the
character dot PNG
copy this paste it in the public folder
let me import this
import profile
character from
slash
public slash
character dot PNG
let's use this on the alt just write
your name
foreign
add width
to full height to pull object to
contain
object position to
Center
now in this div
let's add a class now set the width to 1
by 2.
H2 full
set border Dash right dash 2
model that's solid
border Dash dark
display to flex and justify to
Center let's save this
there is some issue in the Imports
let's directly import it
go to the
public slash
character dot PNG
and it looks nice
now after this do let's add the text
content
create one more div
and h2 tag
and next is the paragraph tag
open the web website content
copy this for the H2
and this paragraph for the
paragraph tag
now in this new let's add class name
set width to 1 by 2
let's play Flags Flex direction to
column
text to
left
items to
start
and justify
to
Center
set padding left and right to 16.
now for the H2
let's set font to bold capitalize
set text size to text Dash 6xl
now in the paragraph tag
add font way to medium
capitalize
and set margin top to 4 and text to base
let's check the width again
here it is 1 by 2 and here is the typo
let's save this
and it looks better
now let's add the skills
for that let's create one component
inside this about folder called skills
dot Js
let's import the skills
now first let's get the skill list from
this website content.txt file
copy this
paste it right here
now let's use the
section add class name set width to full
Flex
Direction 2 Flex Dash column
padding to
modern
Dash bottom Dash 2 order Dash solid
border Dash dark
and text Dash dark as well
let's add one spawn tag
that's right I'm
comfortable in
let's add class name
set font to semi bold text to
4 XL
text color to text accent
after this one let's use the another
list
now there's another list
let's add the class name display to flex
Flex wrap
margin top to eight
justify
to start
now here we will map this skills from
the skills list
skill list dot map
get the item
and index
so let's return the Ally element
inside this all element right item
let's add the class names
font to say my bold
display to inline block
capitalize
and set text size to text Dash to excel
set padding top and bottom two
let's set it to
Phi and pairing left and right too
12.
set border to
order Dash solid and border
Dash dark
set rounded
margin right dash six
and margin bottom dash six as well and
on Hover
let's scale it
to one zero five
add transition
all is
and duration to
200 and add cursor
Dash pointer let's save this
Also let's add the key
let's save this
let's add more padding on left and right
so we have adding two
let's keep it 12.
and now it looks much better
after this skills let's write this
message
open the about page after the skills
let's add H2
and go to the website content
copy this
paste here
and instead of this here
let's add a link
which sends the user to slash contact
let's add the class name
set margin top to eight
onto
semi bold
text to
to excel
self start and not in the center
margin left and right
do
text Dash dark
that's it
now for the link
let's add the class name
set the underline
and line offset two two
let's save this
and it looks great there is no underline
let's add the important tag
and here it is
now this looks much better so the about
Pages completed
we will add this after creating the
contact page so let's open the contact
page
right now we don't have this page
so let's uh
go to the app
create one folder called Contact and add
the
page dot JS file
let's create one function
write export default
function contact
return one section
that says the contact
here it is
now in this contact
in the first view we will render the
Lottie animation
and the second deal we'll use the
contact form
so let's add the class name to this
section set width to full H2 Auto
let's keep it to 75 viewport height
set border Dash bottom Dash 2 2
border Dash solid order Dash dark set
display to Flags set Flags direction to
flex Dash row items to Center justify
to
Center as well
set text color to text Dash dark
let's save this
and here we have audio animation and
contact form
so first let's create one component
for that in the components folder create
one more folder called Contact
and here let's create
Lottie animation dot JS file
now before this let me give you the link
if you open the website content.txt file
there is this link for the Lottie
animation that I have used
so open this link
now I have downloaded this dot Lottie it
is a compressed format that works with
the dollar players so make sure you
download it from here
then
we are going to use
this Dot Low T
slash react dash player
so let's open it as well
go to this GitHub repo
now click on this
let's copy this code
and paste it right here let's change
this app to
Lottie animation
now uh once you download the
animation.json file uh send it to the
public folder so here it is
copy this and send it to the public
folder
so on slash it can access this Lottie
file so just copy the name
thank you
and paste after the slash
let's remove the controls we won't be
needing that
let's remove this div as well
save this
let's import this
let's add some class name
set the display to inline
block
with two
Let's uh set it to
2 by 5
. and set height to full
border
let's write to to model solid and Border
color to dark
let's save this
so uh
for this Lottie animation we have to use
the use Clan directive
let's save this
and it looks great
now for the second div let's add the
class name set width to full
set width to three by five
display Flex Flex direction to column
items to start
and justify to
Center
set padding left and right to 16 and
padding bottom to 8.
first let's uh add the H2
and write let's connect
set font to fold
capitalize it
text size to 4XL
and let's save this
looks great now let's create the form
component
now for this form component we'll be
needing one text email phone number and
one text area so let's close
all of this
and open the react
hook form.com
go to the tools open the form Builder
and here instead of email
Let's uh write the name
type select text
and update
let's add one more
for the email
set its type to
email
let's create
let's create one more
for the telephone
you can just write phone number
and set its type to tell
create
now for the last one let's create uh for
the text area let's name it as a project
details
and select the text area and click on
the create
now let's copy this code
and create the
contact form component inside this
contact folder
contact form dot Js
and paste the code
now here we are going to use this use
form hook
so we have to convert this component
into a client component so write use
client directive
and also change this name to contact
form
let's save this and import this contact
form right here
after the h2 tag
so here is the form let's style this
foreign
let's write all the text
so before the first input right
hello
my name is
then keep the one space
and before the second input right and I
want
to discuss
a potential
yeah
project
you can email me at
so this is the email and before the
phone number right
or
reach out to me on
this phone number then before the text
area right
here are some
details about my
project
that's it
let's save this
now let's style this input
now inside this form let's add the class
name set margin top to 12.
text size to excel
font to medium and
leading to relaxed
and set font to font enter
now for this first input
let's add the class name
set outline
to none
border to zero padding to 0 as well
set margin left and right to
on Focus Let's uh
keep ring to zero and for the
placeholder
set text to
Center let's save this
now this looks much better
let's increase the placeholder text size
set text to LG
then add border bottom
watercolor to border Dash Gray
let's save this
and it looks great now on focus it is
converting the color to Blue so let's
change this
set Focus
order Dash Gray
and background to transparent
let's copy this class name and add
in the email
as well as the
phone number and in the text area let's
save this
now we have to change some classes for
the text area
let's add
rows and keep it to three
set width to full
and after this project add one
VR
now this is much better
Let's uh add the placeholder
that says
my project is about
Dot
let's remove the text Dash Center
for the placeholder
let's change the placeholder for the
name as well
your name
you're at email
thank you
your phone
and let's save this
and this looks much better
now let's uh style this submit button
and the class name
let's add margin top to eight
font wait to font Dash medium display to
inline block
capitalize it
text size to let's keep it to excel
padding top and bottom two
three
padding left and right two
uh let's skip it
border to two powder solid and Border
color to dark
let's keep it rounded and set cursor
to pointer
that's it
let's change its value to send request
instead of submit
foreign
so after the type add value and write
send request
now this looks much better
now let's create this inside role that
goes from right to left
now this inside rule uh does not change
even though I change the about page but
it gives the animation State the same
because uh it is uh shared by the about
and contact page so let's see how we can
leverage the layout functionality and
share share this same component in both
of these pages so that it will not
re-render whenever we change this page
so for that let's check out the next JS
groups
route groups
now let's scroll down
as mentioned here a raw group can be
created by wrapping folders name in
parenthesis
so uh as mentioned here even though
routes inside marketing and Shop share
the same URL hierarchy you can create a
different layout for each group by
adding layout.js file inside their
folders
now here this layout.js file is shared
with account and card pages
so let's do something similar like this
first let's close this
and inside this app folder
let's create one more folder called
about
make sure you use the parenthesis
and in this group we will add the about
and move this contact as well
and inside this about let's create one
file called layout dot chess
now let's export
default function called
about layout
make sure you don't use a root layout
because root layout is uh for the app
folder only
now this layout
will have the children prop
ER let's return
main element
here we will
display the insights
and then that is this children
and the main let's add the class name
set with to full display Flex direction
to column
items two
Center and justify
space between
save this and
check this out
as you can see here that is insights
right here and in this
about page as well
so let's create this role for that let's
create one more component inside this
about called insight
row dot Js
let's import this
right here
now let's go to the website content
copy this insights
and paste it inside the layout
let's pass this and the inside role
component
now from this component let's
deconstruct it
now in this insights you can add any
information about yourself such as years
of experience uh multiple number of
clients
and any achievements that you have
achieved in recent years
and this
now in this do let's add the class name
set width to full
background to
accent
set text to light and white space too
no rap
set overflow to Hidden
and that's it
after this do let's create another view
this div will contain all the text
set width to full padding top and bottom
to three
Flex display to flex
items Center
justify to
Center as well and capitalize
set font weight to semi bold
and
tracking to wider
here the dragging that means lattice
spacing
between the letters
set text to
base
here let's map the insights so inside
start map
text
return one live
and write the text
also with the text
add
one span
and in this one we will add the pipe
symbol
add the class name set button left and
right 2 4
that's it
let's save this
and this looks great now let's uh
animate this for animation we can
customize the keyframes in the
tailwind.config file
so go to the
tailwind.config.js file
now after this font family
let's add animation
and create one animation called roll
we will use roll keyframes
for 24 seconds
linear manner and for finite time
now let's uh add the keyframe
the name of the keyframe is row
now for the zero percent
Let's uh
use
transform
translate X
to 100 percent
copy this and paste it right here
and for the
hundred percent let's transform it to
minus 100 percent
let's
save this and use this animation
uh to use that animation you just have
to write
animate and name of the animation which
is roll
let's save this
and here it is
you can see that whenever I change the
page but uh inside role is same
so this is a really great benefit of
next Js
you don't need to re-render every
component
let me close all this website
and that's it uh our website is almost
completed for the desktop version
let's change the index of this blog
go to the Home Cover section
change
from 1 to 0
save this and in the featured post
change this to one
two
three save this and in recent post
change from
4 to 10.
now uh we have to do this because we
have removed the block dash one
let's add the key right here
let's save this
now let's see how we can store the total
view numbers for each blog now for this
we are going to use the supervis now if
you don't know Super Bass it's okay
uh you don't have to learn more about it
because we are going to use only a
simple function and one table to show
The View count
so let's go to the supervised.com and
create your account and login
so after the login you should see a
screen like this
now let's create one project by clicking
on this new project and if you don't
have any organization
create organization let's name it as
code bugs
now here you can add the project name
let's write
developer log
now for the password let's generate the
password
let's just copy this and store it
somewhere safe
for the region I'm in India so I will
select South Asia
and create new project
now this will take
few seconds to initialize the project in
the meantime you can copy this and on
public key
now this key will be used to
authenticate each and every request from
your application to the super base
and if you don't want to copy it right
now we can copy it later from the
project settings
and the project is initiated
so let's uh go to this table editor I
think there is some problem with the
super base for this particular page
Let's ignore that and create a new table
now let's write the name of the table
let's write fuse
the description you can just say
this table contains log views
uh let's skip this check
and these are the columns uh keep the ID
and created at as it is
add one column let's name it as slug
and for the data type let's select text
let's keep it as null and let's add
another column
write count
and here we will store the total counts
and let's keep its type to integer 4.
and let's save this
so here is our table now let's go to the
SQL editor now here we will create one
function in postgresql
so before that we have to
Grant the permission so that we can
create such a function and different
schema
so for that uh just write
Grant
Grant create on
schema
public to Anon
that's it and let's run this
and it is Success so after this grant
access we can create the function so
let's write create or replace function
called
increment increment is the name of the
function
let's write it now we will pass the slug
uh the last part of the URL for any blog
into this function so uh in the table we
will store that Slug and we will
increment the counter so in the argument
type slug underscore text and type of
this argument will be text
and this function will returns nothing
since uh we don't want anything from
this function this function should only
increment the number in the views table
and write void as
dollar sign
so this line declares the function named
increment that takes a single parameter
that is this log text of type tags and
returns void
so the function definition starts with
this double currency sign indicating the
beginning of a block of postgresql now
press enter and let's declare one
variable
called view underscore ID and type of
the variable is integer
now this line declares a local variable
named view ID of type integer
and let's begin now this begin marks the
beginning of the function's main block
let's write select
ID
into
view underscore ID variable from
views table
where
slug
uh
remember that column we have defined it
is a slug
equal to slug
text and let's limit it to one
let me explain this line
so uh this statement retries the ID from
views table where the slug is equal to
the slug text so let's say uh there is a
Blog which has a slug which is ABCD and
it has five counts so uh let's say if
you want to increment that view for that
particular block so we'll call increment
by passing the ABCD as a slug text and
now this line will first compare if
there is any blog available with the
slug ABCD and if there is then it will
get that ID of that particular row and
store it into the view underscore ID
variable
now let's add a condition so if view
underscore ID is not null
then
we will update the view count so write
update
view stable and set
count column to
count Plus 1.
now where
ID of that row
it should be same as the view underscore
ID
so uh let me summarize this
so first we have declared this variable
and we will select the ID of that row
which has this slug for any particular
Blog then if there is ID available that
means the row is available in the table
then we will update at that particular
row so we have write update views table
where set column named count to count
plus 1 and where ID is equal to view
underscore ID so this this is how we
will update the particular row
else
now code runs into the as block because
view ID is null that means there is no
row available with this particular
particular blog slug so for that we will
create new row so write insert
into views table
for the slug and count column
and we will add the values
the past slug text
and now for the count column let's add
one
that's it let's end the if statement so
n if
and let's end this main block of this
function
and let's end the function definition
and let's write language PL
ql now uh this last line
that marks the end of this function
definition block and specifies that this
function is written in the postgresql
language
so let's uh format this
now let's run this function
and it has some error
let's add semicolon in here let's add
semicolon here as well let's run this
and we have a success
so this will create a one function
called increment and you can see that in
here click on this database
and if you go to these functions
so we have this increment function
and you can edit function or check the
API Docs
so let's uh check if this function works
or not go to the SQL editor
let me create a new query
and to run any function you have to
write select
function name which is increment
and here let's write slug ABCD
let me use single quotes
let's run this
and we have no result but let's check
the table
and as you can see here there is a one
row with the slug ABCD and count to one
now let's run this function again
let's keep the slug to ABCD let's run
this Let's uh run this query again
and let's uh
run it for one more time
let's open the table
and as you can see account is increasing
so let's see how we can connect the
super base to our blog
and you can also refer to this uh API
Docs
you can click on this views table and
this is how you can select edit update
or delete any row
and here is the function
now this is how we can call the function
so let's open the vs code let me close
everything
now if you open this dot ene dot example
you will see there are two way variables
that we are going to use one is the
supervised URL and one is the Anon key
so let's copy this or just change
it's a name from Envy dot example to EnV
dot local
and let's add uh values to this
variables
go to the settings
and click on this API
now here is the project URL so let's
copy this
and paste it right here
let's copy this and on public keys
so let's save this
now open the SRC components folder and
go to the blog and let's create one more
component called view counter dot Js
let's write one save this and go to the
blog details
and instead of this 10 views
let's add the
view counter
let's save this
you can say it says one
so first uh we are going to update this
uh counts on the client side so let's
make it a client component for that
let's add use client directive
now here
to connect the super base we are going
to use super bass slash auth helper
slash uh Dash nextges
so if you open the package.json file and
here is the library that we are going to
use
so first uh let's uh create the Super
Bass instance for that create const
super base equal to create client
component client
make sure you import that from this
Library
now uh here we are going to get
slow of the blog then let's uh add one
more which says no count
so if you don't want to increment the
account uh let's say you want to display
this view counter component in the home
page or to show the total account or
total views of any Blog then you just
have to pass no count equal to false
so that it does not increment the
counter whenever it reloads
and let's add one more prop called show
count
and let's keep it to true
Let's uh add one more state
so just write you state
make sure to import that from the react
let's name it as
views
for now let's skip it to zero
now uh if
show count
is true then we will return this else we
will return null
now in this do let's render this dates
called views and write views let's save
this
and here it is
so for now there is zero views
now let's uh create one
use effect
make sure you import that from the react
now in this use effect let's create one
function
call const
increment View
let's make it async
now we are creating this function inside
this use effect because we are not going
to use this function anywhere out
outside of this use effect
so let's first write the try block
inside this try block let's get the code
to call the function
let's open this
API Docs
click on this increment function and
let's copy this code
and paste it right here
now after this try block let's add catch
pass the error and
we will
use cons console
dot error
and let's write an error
occurred while
incrementing The View count
let's pass the error
now let me explain this code so this
will uh call this function increment and
if it passes the slug underscore text
which in this case it is
Slug and then if this function returns
anything that it will store into data
and if there is an error then it will
store this that message into this
variable so if uh there is any error we
will
log it so if there is any error
let's use
console.error
and let's write
error
incrementing view count inside try block
we don't need this data so let's remove
it
let's copy this function
and if
no count is true
so just write exclamation mark
right no count
and then we will call this
function
and in this use effect dependency let's
write slug
and no count
uh before we save that let's go to the
blog details
and pass the slug
so here is the blogs log
let's save this and save this as well
let's reload this
and we are getting the error it says
incrementing you count inside try block
new row violets row level security
policy for the table views
so for that we have to add a different
policy in this database so go to this
Authentication
and click on this policies so we have no
policies created for this views table
let's create the new policy
click on this get started quickly
now this is the template to enable read
access to everyone let's use this
template now uh we are going to
enable the read access not for all users
but for Anon users that uses that public
key that we have stored in the EnV
variable
so for the Target rules let's select
Anon
and let's keep this expression to true
let's review this
looks great click on the save policy
now let's create another policy
to
edit or insert
select this enable insert
use this template
now enable insert for
and on users only
instead of authenticated select and on
and review let's save this now let's uh
add one more policy
for the update
click here
let's use this template
and let's change it to
and on
users
let's select the Anon
now let's remove this expression and
just write true
and true
let's review this
and save the policy
so we have three policy insert read and
update for all and on users
Let's uh refresh this
let's refresh this again
let's check the table
and here it is now as you can see here
we have two counts for this blog and
here is here is the slug now let's try
for the another blog
let's click on this
and as you can see here it has uh
created one row for the JS Frameworks
comparison blog
now let's see how we can get this views
so go to the API Docs
and click on the views table
now let's see how we can get the view
count so this is the code
let's create a almost same use effect
let's change this function name to get
views
and instead of that
let's copy this
so uh here we are first selecting the
table from table let's select the count
column now let's use uh another
condition
and after that we will use dot match
let's match the
slug column with the given slug value
if there is a match let's return the
single row
and once we get this views
Let's uh
set this date so right side views
and pass the
views
now before this first let's log it
let's remove this views and keep the
data
let's log the data save this
and instead of calling this
let's call get views
we don't need this condition
and no count as well let's save this
now here is the data we are getting four
count
so let's set the state
if there is data
then set data dot count otherwise
set 0.
let's remove this log save this
and as you can see here it says four
views
let me reload this
and it says five views so it is working
great
now let me close this tab so this is how
you can create a view counter and store
its value to the supervised
you can use supervised to add different
functionalities as well
now let's learn one of the important
part of this blog that is the SEO now
before that let's open the next.js docs
make sure you are in the app router
and go to the optimization
click on the metadata
now there are two ways by which you can
add the SEO a one is by defining this
metadata object and in this object you
can add different information such as
title description Etc
and you can add this metadata in the
layout.js file as well so that this SEO
will be shared across all the pages all
the routes
and next is the dynamic metadata that
uses the generate metadata function
so uh this function is uh usable for the
dynamic Pages such as blogs and
categories for blogs and categories we
are not creating Pages individually for
each and every blog instead we are using
the page.js file and we are using the
dynamic routes so for that we are going
to use the generate metadata function so
let's add this metadata constant
foreign
let me close this
now go to the app directory
and open the layout.js file well there
is already one constant called metadata
so let's uh add the required SEO inside
this metadata so that it will be shared
across all the routes now let's edit
this metadata
so first let's add the URL now before we
add any data into this metadata object
first let's create one file called site
metadata
so go to the utils
and create one file called site meta
data dot JS now in this file we will
create one constant called
site
metadata
here we will add all the required data
that that are important for our blog
you can go to the project files and open
the site metadata.js and just copy this
and paste it right here now in the side
method data we have title of this blog
other Adder title uh description
language theme site URL uh for me it is
this URL that I have hosted on the
virtual so you can change this whenever
you host your blog we have a logo social
Banner now this logo and social winner
you should have uh both of this PNG
files inside the public directory so in
the project files
let's copy the social banner.png
and this is just a screenshot of the
website
and paste it inside the public folder
now I already have this profile Dash
image so let me copy this and paste it
inside the public directory again let me
change its name to logo
let me close all this
and then we have email Social Links and
local
so we are going to use this site
metadata
for the SEO let's close this open the
layout
now let me open the next.js docs
click on the static metadata object
so here are all the fields that we can
add into this metadata so first let's
add the metadata base now as mentioned
here it is an option to set the base URL
so let's copy this
and paste it right here
now inside this we will add the URL
first import the site metadata
object then write site URL
make sure to import that
it should not be from the project file
so let me import this again
from YouTube's
let's save this now let's open the title
so here is the title you can uh add the
title as simply as that or we can use
the template
so uh
click on the template
as you can see uh
template has percentage s for the string
and Acme is the website's name so uh
whenever we pass let's say in the blog
route we will write the blog title and
at the end it will add this website's
name
so let's use this template copy this
and instead of this
let's
use the template and default in the
default
let's get this site metadata Dot
title
and in the template as well copy this
and instead of Acme write the currency
symbol and parenthesis and paste this
make sure uh these are the backticks
so in different routes whenever we pass
the title it will be right here and
after that title there will be a site
title
let's save this
and we load this
now as you can see here we have the site
title
now after this we will add the
description
let's use the site metadata again
dot description
now let's add the open graph images so
that it will help social media to
preview our blog
let's click on this open graph
let's copy this
and paste it right here now in this open
graph
let's add site metadata dot title
in this title
and for the description as well for the
URL we will use this
now for the site name let's keep the
title
now for this images
let's just pass
site
metadata dot social Banner
which you can see
that is this URL
let's keep local a as it is and type 2
as it is as well
now let's go to the robots
let's copy this
paste it right here now uh it says false
but if you
write true it will it will enable your
blog to be indexed by other search
engines
and this is for the Google board
let's delete this
you can add or update any settings you
want from this
and let's scroll down
the viewport is automatically set with
the following default value so we don't
have to add this
let's add Twitter
copy this
and paste it after this robots
for the title we will use site metadata
dot title
let's keep the card type 2 as it is
let's remove the description site ID
creator
Creator ID and for the image we will use
social Banner
let's save this
and let's open this
now inside the inspect elements open the
head
now you will see all the metadata that
we have added
now here is the OG URL site name local
image type and Twitter card title
description
[Music]
and here is the description of this page
and title as well
so this metadata will be common across
all the routes
so this is completed now let's see how
we can add the metadata for dynamic
routes let's go to the documentation
and
click on this
generate metadata function
let's just copy this
and let me close all this open the
blog page
after generate generate static params
let's paste this
and here we will add all the SEO related
to the blog so first let's get the data
for individual blog we can
copy this
and paste it inside this function so
this is how we will get the block data
now this function will have params
object so that it can access this log
and all other information
and
let's say if there is no blog
return
nothing
now first uh let's add the log dot title
then
the description as well
now let's uh
copy the opening graph
let's go to the
open graph
let's copy this
and paste it right here
now for the title let's use
block Dot
title and description as well
for the URL we will use
site metadata make sure to import that
from the utils
Plus
add slash blogs
add params Dot
slug that's it or you can just write
blog
dot URL
that we are getting
from here
and this is the URL but this will start
from the slash blogs so we have to
eventually add the site metadata Dot
site URL
oops it should be
here
all right now for the site name
let's add the site metadata
Dot
title
now let's add local and type right here
and type set article
now for the article there is a more
Fields such as published
time
so let's calculate this publish time and
date
create one variable called const
published at and let's
use new date pass the blog Dot
published
at
and let's convert this to to ISO string
let's do the same for the updated as
well let's change this name to modified
add
and here change it to updated at
r
let's just write
blog dot date
do we have that field
let me check this once again
we have blog dot image author text body
we don't have a date instead we can use
this publish date if there is no updated
add date
so let's copy this paste it right here
and next field is the
modified
time
let's copy this and paste it right here
now there is one more field for the
image so let's create uh one variable to
store the image list
so in this array first pass the site
metadata Dot
social Banner
and let's check if this Blog has the
cover image so okay let's put a
condition says if log dot image
then
let's add it to the image list
image list equal to first we will check
the type of blog dot image Dot
file path
So eventually we are checking this it
should be string
file path if it is string
and let's add
the this image URL so for that we will
use site metadata Dot site URL
Plus
log dot image dot file path
and let's replace
uh this dot dot slash public
dot replace
dot dot slash public
Within empty string
so this will add the log image
else let's just
set the image list to blog dot image now
in this images we have to pass the URLs
of each image
so let's create one more variable called
OG
images equal to
image list
dot map
this will give us the image
and let's return
the URL
so return one object
write URL and let's add a condition if
this image
includes
http
then return the image as will create
this
URL
with using site metadata Dot site URL
plus the image
actually we don't have to do this
condition but
still it is better to be safe than sorry
let's copy this
and
instead of this array let's add the OG
images
now let's add the author
so for the author let's create one
variable called authors equal to
let's say if block has the author
then return one added and add block dot
author as
we will use the author from the site
metadata
dot author
in our case it is code bugs
let's copy this
and add one more field called authors
if authors dot length is greater than
zero
it should be authors
and then others else
add site metadata
dot author
that's it now let's add the Twitter card
go to the layout
and
let's copy this
and paste it right here
we have card
and state outside metadata.title at blog
dot title
and let's add the discussion as well
now for the images
let's add
image list uh
this OG images
let's save this and let's check it out
let's open this blog
now as you can see on this tab it has
the title of the blog
let's open the
elements
open the head
and here are all the meta tags
here is the publish date and modified
date
and here is the published time and
modified Time author
let's check if it has the OG image and
here is the Twitter image
so first we have the site URL from the
site metadata then slash blog slash this
image which is the cover image of this
blog
so everything looks great
let me close this let's add SEO for this
categories page
let's open the categories page.js
let's copy
this
and paste it right
after the generate static params
let's remove this we don't need this as
well let's move
everything
accept title and description
if you want different images for the
social media you can just modify this
for the title let's use
backdicks
and right
currency symbol and parenthesis
let's add the category name which is
parents dot slug
then just write
vlogs
and in the description
let's add back text
let's write learn more
about
let's add params
dot slug that is the category name
learn more about XYZ category
through our
collection of expert
blogs and tutorials
let's save this
and here is the category name and blogs
now let's remove this Dash
so dot slug
dot replace all
replace steel Dash
with once
space
let's save this
let's reload it again and
actually I should do this
and the title
and it looks much better
now uh
for the all category this does not
look much better for the description
now as mentioned it says learn more
about all through our collection so
let's add one condition here
let's say if firearm starts lug
equal to
all then just write web
development
else let's pass the category name that
is params Dot
slug so let's save this
and now it says learn more about web
development through our collection of of
expert blogs and tutorials now this
looks much better now let's uh add the
metadata for the
contact and about page let's open the
contact page
open the layout
let's just copy this now in this contact
page we don't need to use the generate
metadata function because this is not
dynamic
let me remove this Twitter
open graph
and this title as well
let's remove this
now in the title let's just write
contact me
and in the description
let's just write
this
contact me through
this form
are
email me at
Let's uh just write your email instead
of this
let's use backdicks paste this and
let's get the email from site metadata
which is right here
so just write
site metadata
let's import this from the utils DOT
email
that's it let's save this
copy this and open the about page
and paste it right
here
or the title
let's just use about me
here are
some details about myself
that's it let's save this and check it
out go to the contact
and here is the title and in the
description it says contact me through
this form or the email email me at uh
codebox27 gmail.com let's open the about
and this looks great
let me change
this like contact me through this
through
the form
available on this page or email me at
this
and much better let me close all this
now our website is almost completed now
for this social media links let's get
the URL from the site metadata so open
the header
and here are all the URLs so instead of
this
open curly braces
import site metadata from utils Dot
first let's write LinkedIn
then there is Twitter
then we have GitHub and
retriever
so if you open the site metadata here
are all the social media links
let's copy this and do the same for the
footer links
so instead of example
let's replace this with this
change this to Twitter
GitHub
and
triple let's save this
we should import the site metadata
from utils
and this is pointing to the right URL
all right now let's implement the theme
switcher button let's go to the
components folder
and create one folder called
hooks
and let's start creating the
use theme switch hook
right use then switch make sure to add
use keyword before you create any react
hooks
let's write
choose Clan directive
and let's export one function called use
theme
switch
and this function first let's uh get the
preferred dark query
so let's write
prefer
dark
query
or we can also say preference theme or
something like that
so this is one of the median queries
that prefers color schema
to dark
we will use this media query if there
are no user preference available
and we will use the local storage to
store the theme
so for that just write storage key
and set it to
Tim
that's it now let's create a function to
toggle the theme so const
toggle theme
let's pass the theme
if
theme is equal to equal to dark
then
we will add the dark class
in the HTML so just write document Dot
document element which is the HTML and
let's add dot class list
dot add and add the dark class
now else we will remove this dark class
so just change this add to remove
now after that let's uh
add the theme in the local storage so
just writing window
dot local storage dot set item
storage key that is the theme and
for the value use the past theme
so after this function let's initialize
the theme
so let's uh
create one function that check if there
is any user preference or not
so const get user
preference
so in this function
pause let's create one variable called
user pref
and
first let's uh get the theme from the
local storage so just write window dot
local storage dot get item
and pass the
storage key
now if
there is something in the local storage
so that means the user has some
preference
then
return the user preference it can be
dark or light
as let's return the system preference so
for that we are going to use this media
query so just write window dot match
media
and let's add this query
dot matches if this query uh that says
prefers color a schema to Dart that
means the system uh preferred color
schema is dark
then we will return the Target also we
will return the light
now
after this functions let's
initialize one use State make sure to
import that from the react
let's name it as a mode you can also set
its name to theme
let's set this to
dark
now let's use both of this function in
an use effect so
Let's uh import this from react
okay
now in this use effect
first let's get the media query
we will use this media query to check
the system preference
right match media
and
copy this query and paste it right here
now after that let's create one function
called handle change
and let's get the user preference using
this function
copy this
let's write one variable
called new mode
this variable will store the user
preference
so after that let's uh set this mode
pass the new mode
and after this let's toggle the theme
let's copy this new mode right here
and let's call this function
so now whenever this page reloads it
will run this use effect and first it
will run this function and get the
preference of the user then it will set
the mode and toggle the theme as well
now after that when the page is already
loaded and let's say user click on the
theme switch button then we have to
detect that change and make a change in
the theme as well so for that we will
add one event listener
on this query so just write
media query dot add event listener
write change
on any change
we will call the handle change function
so that's it now let's uh
close this event listener on return
so right media query let's just copy
this
paste it right here and just add remove
event listener
let's remove this
after this user file let's return the
mode and set mode function
let's save this and let's use this hook
inside the header
now we are going to use this user in
this header so we have to make it as a
client component
so let's use mode and set mode
from the use sim switch hook
make sure to import it
now in this button
let's create one function called on
click
on click on this button Let's uh use a
set mode function
so if mode is equal to the current mode
is equal to
light
then set the value to Dart I'll skip the
value to light that's it let's save this
and test this hook
let me click on this
actually let's go to the layout
and let's add uh one class for the dark
mode
click on the dark set the bg2 DOT
let's save this
and as you can see it is working great
let me click again and it is not working
let's check the hook
so we have on use effect uh when the
page reloads
but we don't have anything that handles
the change in the mode state
so let's create one more use effect
now in this use effect this will run
whenever any change happens in the mode
and calls the toggle theme function by
passing the value of this mode let's
save this now let's go to the
Tailwind config
here we have to add the dark mode
let's open
Tailwind CSS
click on the dark mode
and here it is
now we have to
set this configuration
right here
let's save this
and check this
and it's working great
let's reload it it is uh changing from
light to dark so that is not good
now let's scroll down
and we have to add the script on the
page load
so let's copy this
go to the layout
and before the header and inside this
body let's use the script tag to add the
script
make sure you import that from the next
slide script
Let's uh add one curly braces
and Matrix and add the script now
it will check if the theme is dark and
that is theme in or that is theme in
local storage and mesh media query and
if this all matches then it will add the
dark class as it will remove the dark
class now this script is necessary
because whenever we reload the page this
should run and check the local storage
before it loads all the elements
so let me just modify this let's just
write local storage.get item
theme and it should be dark
let's add one more single code let's
let's save this
and we format it
and it looks great now let's uh make
this website responsive and add the dark
dark class whenever required first let's
start with the logo
thank you
now here it is text Dash dog now for the
dark set text to light
let's save this
and this looks much better
let's change the Border dark to border
light for the Dark theme
change border to light
let's save this
and much better
thank you
let's decrease the font weight for this
code books
for the dark set font weight to
semi bold
and looks great
let's make it responsive
now we are going to use the minimum
width query if you
search the responsive design
here it is
now this Tailwind use minimum width
for the SM it is 640 and for the 2XL it
is a 1536 pixel let's use all this
now in the logo
Let's uh decrease the width to width
dash 12 for the medium screen so just
write MD
set with 212.